okay I'd like to welcome everybody to
the education committee today we have in
the morning we have scheduled uh a
number of executive sessions for
numerous bills here followed in the
afternoon by hearings on on on four
bills so with that I'd like to get into
our executive session be it noted that
when we are in executive session for the
public we do not have to take any
specific bill in the order that is
printed in the calendar we can jump
around wherever we may go um this is
basically a a process which is for the
committee to discuss these bills and
take action on the bills it's not a
session where we take uh input from the
public unless the committee requests
technical
support so with that uh I'd like to
start out and I will take the first bill
on the docket this is HP
1048 this is relative to the commission
uh on the Holocaust and
genocide uh
education
me yes
please uh yes uh House Bill 1048
relative to the commission on Holocaust
and genocide education uh call upon
chairman lad for a motion yes uh thank
you uh representative cordelli I I put
second second second
Miler further yes I'd like to put forth
an amendment for this
bill I believe everybody has it uh in
front of them um the amendment is uh
0244 and I put forth that motion as an
amendment to the bill uh second second
by represent
Miler a comment um chairman lad yes
uh addressing the issue of the Holocaust
and
genocide education in our classrooms is
extremely
important and it is so important that
the legislature and this in the the
Senate and and the governor we put it
into the adequacy portion of our our
statutes we have a commission that's
been tasked with addressing how we uh
look at and address the teaching of this
in in our schools it comprises people
from all over the
state and it also involves the Cohen uh
Institute or school at keing State
College and a wonderful
institution um what we've done in the
amendment here the we have
uh have the reporting date as 2026
rather than 2027 encouraging this report
and this commission to get reports to
us and in a timely manner and also to
emphasize that as printed in the
commission responsibilities right now an
annual report shall be submitted onor
before there's a date November 1 2021
and each year thereafter the report has
not been submitted
and we feel that report's important for
for the legislature to just know what's
going on and what progress being made
and we we hope that the the commission
we know the commission has met we're not
negating that we've seen the
subcommittee meetings on the website so
with that this bill this amendment
simply drops the date down one year as
far as this act shall take uh effect
27 thank you Regent Miler
anything uh any further discussion from
the committee yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair could you just
comment about the testimony we heard was
that the commission thought they needed
four years of implementation of the bill
to achieve the intended
results so are we perceiving an earlier
report as kind of an interim report no
we are looking at one we have not seen
any report to date I sure you're
concerned that that is a concern but
also this is a very important topic
given the nature of what's happening in
our society today and stringing this out
for that length of a time we're trying
to get it a little earlier so we can get
on with doing what we need in our
schools thank you anything
further
uh seen no further comments or questions
amendment Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes Representative beler
no representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
cortiella yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative albone yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lead
yes 19 y one
day uh further motion yes chairman lad
thank you represent Corelli I recommend
otpa for house bill um 1048 second
second by representative Myer any
further discussion on the uh bill as
amended yes representative
Belcher thank you Mr chairman I just
want to explain that I have a slightly
different mind on this bill I too look
at our um our current
circumstances I see what appears to be
an unprecedented wave of hatred and an
unprecedented wave of
anti-Semitism and I am deeply troubled
by this now we the entire State of New
Hampshire are awaiting the findings of
this committee a commission rather um
from our legislation here to the
executive branch in order to proceed
with making recommendations um on this
topic I think we need this report in
hand yesterday now that's not possible
so I think November would have to do but
I'm certainly not in favor of extending
it I think this is something we need to
um really expedite so that's that's my
feelings on this thank
you any further comments uh seen none um
Madam clerk
otpa VI chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher no
representative dry yes representative
Representative peternell
no Representative corello no
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Heath he representative Heath it's okay
representative
wock
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative casavan yes
representative Damon
yes chairman lad yes 16 days four days
thank you very much we used to have a
policy on the committee representative
Heath I don't or representative Woodcock
I don't know where
that for
okay okay it used to be that the
person's phone went off and not it's
lunch the coffee F yeah well I'm going
back to the days of Representative guile
yeah yeah L wow yeah and then we
downgraded it to coffee but we we had
lunch I'm putting mine on mute right now
that's why nobody can ever get a hold of
me because I keep it off okay the next
1690 that we didn't have enough votes
bill that consent I'm
sorry I were you doing a Minority Report
I didn't think
so you do okay you don't need one
no
well that was the whole point wasn't it
yeah but yeah we will discuss that later
was it not consent no it's not on
consent
no okay the the next bill which we have
1690 and I I Look to representative
perel for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move um itl
on House Bill
1690 is there a second second we have a
motion made by representa Pell and
second by representative
luno representative Pell do you care to
speak to your motion yes thank you um
House Bill 1690 is a bill which
prohibits in any institution of higher
education that discriminates an
admission hiring promotion graduation or
admission to any program on the B basis
of sex race sexuality national origin
ethnicity or ideology including but not
limited to permitting diversity equity
and inclusion statements from accepting
funds from the state or any local
government or any subdivision thereof
and it further establishes procedures
for enforcement of this prohibition um
this bill establishes a new chapter of
Law and applies to public private
nonprofit and for-profit which would be
difficult to enforce
students and employees are already
protected from discrimination under
current statute and if this bill were
enacted and penalties needed to be
enforced the colleges and universities
would not be able to honor their
commitments very well
done further
discussion I agree uh any further
discussion from the
committee Madam clerk would you please
call the role Vice chairman cordelli yes
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes Representative
beler no representative dry yes
representative McDonald
yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 19 y one day any
objections to consent thank you so that
will go on to
consent uh going down to the next bill
which we
have uh is establishing a program to
earn tuition credits uh Community
Service uh that's HB 1534
FN
Mr chair I'm going to recognize uh
representa McDonald thank you Mr chair
and I'd like to move in Durham study
second that okay we have a motion for
interim study made by represent McDonald
you discussion yes please um I like this
bill and there's no question that we
have a student crisis and addressing the
extreme High Cost of college and higher
education would remedy this issue and HB
1534 is a potential Solution by granting
tuition credits to truly deserving and
motivated students I believe this bill
has the potential to become excellent
law for those reasons however the cost
of the department to administer this
program and a few other concerns would
ultimately decrease the funding
available to students if this motion
passes I'd like to work closer with the
sponsor to address these concerns yet
all in all Morgan the high school
student who drafted this bill has every
reason to take pride not only in it but
also in the positive example she sets
for her peers to get involved in the
Civic process and that's all I have to
say thank you thank you from the second
is there I would repeat those exact
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the role Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
elure yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
Pell yes
yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 208 z
a okay that goes on consent as
well thank you very much uh next bill
which we have is HB
1675 adequacy grants based on pupil
performance proficiency excuse me
proficiency uh look to uh representative
cordelli for a motion uh I move uh itl
on this is there a
second we have a motion made by
representa cordelli uh and second by
representative Miler to for itl
representative cordelli would you like
to speak to your motion uh thank you I I
understand the uh intent of the uh
sponsors to try and promote uh
proficiency and um U put some
accountability
into the requirement for Proficiency in
our schools it's a a certain concern to
everybody uh but I think the um punitive
Direction um of this um is something
that uh especially in uh the way it's
laid out um I I cannot uh support um I
think um my preference would be to see
um incentives as we have had Tri
uh I guess it was last year uh so for
that reason um uh I move
itl further discussion on the
bill yes represent
leus I would love incentives we didn't
seem to get any support on incentives
which is why I was trying this one um
hopefully next year we'll get we'll see
some incentives that's what I would like
to see uh
I do think though that we have to
do
something to
encourage schools to take a different
direction because the direction they're
taking is clearly not
working um and as I said before I'm not
asking teachers to work harder I'm
asking them to work differently I'm
asking school districts to work
differently to get set goals differently
to teach reading for instance in a way
that we know from evidence-based
research works as opposed to teaching
reading in a way that we know doesn't
work and the same for
math
so as I said before I tried incentives I
tried just basic
accountability so I'm trying this mostly
to hope to motivate people one way or
another to take a second look at the way
we're doing
education to try to
um change how we're doing things because
how we're doing things now is not
working further discussion represent
cordial thank you Mr chair so I was a
co-sponsor of this bill and the reason
is
that I really like the fundamental idea
of trying to fix we can all agree that
education needs to be fixed and many of
the things we're doing are not working
as evidenced by all the low test scores
and I could go on and on about that but
um I like to look at things to
understand things I like to look at
analogies and to me what I first thought
of when I saw this bill
was if you go to a restaurant and you
are waited
on
adequately you leap 20% tip I know years
ago it used to be 15 but nowadays you
leave a 20%
tip if you're not waited on
adequately I well I don't leave a 20%
tip I might leave a 10% tip if I'm
waited on very inadequately and I think
that does provide an incentive this is
not punitive I don't like that word I
would not have signed on to this if I
thought it was punitive we're not
punishing the stents we're trying to
incentivize teachers and administrations
to think outside the box and do things
in a different way um I work at a public
library as you all know and um I
sometimes hear that some people say If
This Were a business it would be out of
business and I I have to agree so I
think in our public institutions we need
to start thinking outside the box in
terms of
um you know this this analogy of of
running an effective business of seeing
it in that way and so that's why I
co-sponsored this and why I will oppose
itl thank you very much are there is
there further discussion represent
Miler I don't think there's anybody
thank you Mr chair I don't think there's
anybody on this committee that's not
concerned about proficiency scores Etc
but what I'm concerned about is uh
what's available to schools to move in
that
direction and when you have schools that
have um
teacher uh tenure being very short you
have Superintendent at tenure is very
short and they move around the issue of
consistency in curriculum is very
difficult to achieve further we've
talked a lot in this committee about uh
adequate adequate Aid to schools and if
you've got a class size of 35 in a uh
third grade classroom or 35 in a sixth
grade classroom it's very hard for a
teacher to be able to attend to all
those issues so to me in order to begin
to really look at proficiencies you've
got to look at it from a systemic
standpoint and not did from a standpoint
of taking away a grant because a school
is not as proficient as we would all
like them to be thank
you yes represent Tanner just very
quickly I I disagree with the statement
that we all agree that's the public
schools are failing they're not
miserably failing um I've also on many
times in this committee talked about how
proficiency scores are a
nebulous um score that a bar that's set
by um the testing and the scores that
are declared by the either the
government on the doe or at the federal
level and are not they they don't give a
true picture of what's happening in
schools we don't do anything on um
growth uh we haven't talked about growth
at all and I think a lot of our schools
are doing a great job with growth same
thing with reading proficiency um I'd
also take umbrage to the statement that
instead of teaching things that don't
work if a teacher realizes that
something's not working and they do
every day with children because if you
have 30 or 35 or even 15 in your class
you have to reach those 15 kids often
many of them in a different way and
teachers are trained to be flexible and
to to offer different ways of of
learning that's what happens with
reading unless they're they're forced
into a box which some of our legislation
does um so I guess that's that's I just
don't want it to go without some
rebuttal on that I I'd like to chime in
on that and follow up on what represent
Tanner just mentioned um several years
back we changed how we look at the
Statewide assessments and the results
from that it's not necessarily we hope
to get everybody yes in that
quartiles three and four two year a
little bit below for proficiency and and
one year way off course um but what we
want to be looking at is growth of the
students and there are districts which
we absolutely know and we've done the
comparative studies too that there is a
relationship between certain issues uh
of of even if you look at poverty or
property valuation and the achievement
of students uh there are a lot of
variables that must be considered but
when we see a school that's showing
growth and recognizing yes we need to
improve our math scores I'm in one of
those districts and we've gone through
and just overhauled the math program in
the last year or so and in the process
of doing it and professional development
parallels that that we're seeing
tremendous um attitude changes we're
seeing growth changes we're seeing uh
students coming out with the ability to
uh show that they're proficient in these
these competency areas this also lends
to a discussion about our academic
standards and what we have in our
Frameworks and what we have in and
what's going on in schools sometimes
that Statewide assessment doesn't
parallel what's going on in the school
necessarily or the order in which that
course is offered one school district
might offer a course in grade nine where
other might offer that in grade 10 or 11
but what happens if the test is given in
grade nine the ones taken grades 10 or
11 haven't had that course yet so the
scores are obviously going to be low
then the last conversation I want to
have here is that there are districts
app point to represent uh Heath District
of Manchester where there is a number of
students which are coming in now that
are not proficient in
English and we used to call it bilingual
education now it's English language
Learners and that is going to impact
where you are in the Statewide
assessment even though there's
Alternative forms of that assessment can
be given but it's going to impact they
don't have the preceding information
that's been taught in those other grades
that they're being tested in so there
are a lot of issues on this and I think
the this issue is a very complex issue
and and this particular bill doesn't
accomplish what I think the ultimate
leus I understand that
teachers try to do what they can to come
up with ways of teaching kids I also
understand that they don't have the
freedom to do that in a lot of cases
because the curriculum has been chosen
and that's what they have to teach by
and that's what they're told to teach by
even if that curriculum isn't working
and
so part of the point of this was to
get um School boards
superintendents
to look at what the curriculum is that
they are pushing and
demanding
and perhaps give teachers more freedom
to think outside the box and come up
with something that works as opposed to
we will be teaching this even though
this doesn't work thank you
representative Damon then represent
Hall thank you Mr chair I strongly
support the on this bill I think that if
this protocol were implemented it would
be taking money from the districts where
it is most
needed I think
it with appreciation of the sponsor's
intent to improve things I think it
disrespects the capacity of our teachers
and what they are doing to teach
different students in different ways
that work for them it's not a grip Bill
representative Hall thank you Mr chair I
just want to comment on what was what um
representative Lakers just said when
curriculum isn't working I don't think
it's about curriculum I mean curriculum
is what we teach how we teach is a
totally different story right it's a
hugely different so if you're teaching
reading your
curriculum is a reading curriculum but
how you or let's go to math how you
teach it your job is to make sure that
you teach the curriculum so I I think
there's a difference between the two
represent beler and represent whitcock
thank you Mr chair just just to quickly
comment I think the sponsors of this
bill have identified a very good and
important Target uh like any Target I
think there's multiple ways to get at it
I think at this time this is not the
optimum angle of attack on this
particular um Target but I do look
forward to supporting several other
angles that are going to be coming
up represent
Woodcock chairman lad um just I want to
sort of refrain and
what represent Hall said as regards
comments from president leas uh the
curriculum is established but the
pedagogy is not um and the teachers
develop a toolbox of how to work with
youngsters and that toolbox is what
allows teachers to be skilled and have
youngsters meet where they are and go
forward so I don't think it's a case of
being they aren't allowed to do what
they choose to do I think the teachers
are very efficient and taking their
skills that they Master over years
obviously not the first two or three
after they Master over years and are
able to reach different levels of
youngsters so I just want to make the
clear I I don't see it as a teacher
inefficiency in this case thank you
further questions representative Celli
uh thank you just going back to the
conversation between representative
lakas and representative Hall um I I
think there is a curriculum aspect to
this uh last year on my literacy um
initiative I worked with a special Leed
reading
specialist who was in a school where
they taught by the now disproven method
of reading instruction all the reading
materials she fought to have that
changed for three years finally gave up
and left and went to a different school
where they used evidence-based um
methods and instruction so um I think
there is an aspect to what
representative lakas was talking about
yes representative perel thank you Mr
chair um I understand what
representative leus is trying to do with
this bill and
um probably education has been moving
along in a similar pattern for a very
long time and I just want to draw
attention to chapter 194e Innovation
schools and I think that if we want to
make some changes we should probably be
encouraging schools to take a look at
this chapter of Law and and local
districts could actually start to make
some Innovative changes on their
own further discussion representative
Ford thank you Mr chair um I think
there's another aspect of this that also
needs to be considered and it's the
assessment process by which we determine
that a student is not progressing so
forth a recent experience is with doing
teachers with training teachers who are
Paras and adults and take the courses
after the fact has established that they
don't do well on the practice test
unless they take the practice test after
they've had the course addressing that
subskill and then they do very
successfully but if you delay it for a
while it gets lost in all the other new
things they're doing and they don't
perform well on the test and yet if you
do it in sequence one after another they
invariably pass so it's just one of
those kinds of of things like is the
assessment not timed correctly with when
they learn the material and it's it's a
real
question if they don't remember it
because the test is given later they
didn't know it but for me the thing that
says we're not proficient is not a test
it's the fact that they get to college
and can't do the B it don't have the
basic skills the fact that colleges have
to do remediation means that we are
graduating kids that don't have the
skills that they need and for me that's
the ultimate
test any further discussion from the
committee not seeing Madam clerk would
you please call the
rooll vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative leus
no representative
Ford
beler
yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble
no representative Pell
yes Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes
representative balbon yes representative
cascan yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 y four
Nays Minority Report yes okay and I I uh
suppose your motion would be out to pass
correct
yes okay so we are done with that bill
now 1675 we've completed the next bill
1402 um I'm not going to be taking
action on that I understand that
represent leus you do have an amendment
is that correct yeah has that been
passed out to
everybody okay so I and some people are
just getting it right now so we're going
to provide everybody an opportunity to
look that over so we're jumping over
this
bill um and then we'll come back and
discuss this bill and have represent
leus walk through that uh I'd like to
get to the next bill
yeah yeah I want to read the bill though
it's about mandatory elected public
school curricula and I Look to
representa Miler for a motion I move itl
and I'll second
it represent Miley you're yeah this yeah
this bill is just way too prescriptive
uh it it is not it's not the
responsibility of this committee to
outline and a dictate what books should
be read
Etc and uh
uh when I first heard this first heard
of this bill and read the bill I just
shook my head because I it's just I
don't think I've ever seen a bill uh
come before this committee that is that
has this kind of dicta to it as far as
what should be taught what book should
be read and what sequence it should be
read it's just way too much so that's
chair and and I have no further
discussion on either so we will move on
to committee
discussion here further committee
leus I want to say that I very much like
the direction that this is going in I
think this these are things that
definitely need to
be um part of the
curriculum but I have to agree
that this would be something that if I
was a school board member I might be
pushing for but but from our place it is
a little bit too
much telling local school districts
exactly what they need to do but somehow
I do agree this needs to be
done further
discussion representative
um having taught in college and having
students unable to Define what communism
even is so many students getting through
12 years of school and and being unable
to to even recognize that and I have to
teach them this to them as if they've
never heard anything about this before I
see the need for more education on um
this egregious political philosophy that
destroys countries so I commend repres
pres Belcher for all of his work on
this however um I I think this would all
the points that are in here would be a a
wonderful syllabus for a college level
course um I have to agree with with
others that it's just a bit too too
detailed um and not appropriate for um
the middle and high
school further further discussion
representative
Ford unlike perhaps most people in this
room I took this course it's required in
Arizona for every College private public
whatever to teach americanism versus
communism as a two credit course and it
doesn't matter where you went to
school you had to take that course or
you couldn't graduate state law it was a
useful course
it brought together a lot of things I
knew a little about a little about here
and all that but it put it together in a
focus that left you with an
understanding of the basically the DU ju
the position
between the kind government we have and
the kind of government exists in those
kinds of countries and it was not
terribly complicated it could have been
a high school's scor maybe AP perhaps
but nonetheless a high School course but
it certainly could be a college course
and it was a good
course further discussion representative
pel thank you Mr chair I agree with
everything that representative Miler
said however I would recommend that this
bill be forwarded along to the
commission on Holocaust and genocide
education so they could take some of
this coursework into consideration to
further their
studies further discussion represent Bel
thank you Mr chair and I and I indeed
have heard some Fair
criticisms um for those who are opposed
to this bill based on the over
prescriptive nature of it or the
particular content of it fair point and
I totally understand that I would argue
on the other side however that when it
comes to local
control at the moment it does appear
that this body and this committee is
just about the only people out there not
prescribing local curriculum local
curriculum is coming from the federal
government the Department of Education
it is coming from the United Nations and
UNESCO it is coming from local school
boards as well it's coming from NOS who
are providing free curriculum to schools
and of course that is very um beneficial
for schools to not have to pay for it so
they will obviously quickly accept a lot
of free stuff that's coming
in um and I believe our constituents
sent us here as their representatives to
reform schools and fix the problems that
are existing in them this bill is one
step toward that process and again I
take I take the fair
criticism and if this goes down the way
I think it will I will not prevent
consent but I still support this Bill
thank you further discussion representa
Tanner again I would say that we all
were not elected to reform education so
please don't put on us what you feel
your constituents have put on you not
seeing Oh represent woodc
just a an answer right um having been a
social stud teacher at one point uh the
a class America of comparative political
systems picks us up so there is there is
exposure to students who are interested
in that at the high school level if
their school obviously or through the
the uh actually through the um the
online portal as well so here's access
but I do agree with all of it
representative forward that that this is
a PR college level course the way it's
prescripted
thank you very much and not see any
further hands for discussion I would ask
the Madam clerk to call the role Vice
chairman cordelli a motion is itl excuse
me go ahead okay yes
yes representative
leus yes representative
Ford
no Representative
beler no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative
Noble
no representative Pell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman l yes
17 y three Nays any objections to
consent thank you we'll put on
consent
W
okay
well what were you saying oh he's going
to do it for the not you okay okay thank
you got
the next bill
1128 definition of scholarship
organization I will look to representa
please I would like to move itl is there
a
second second by represent um beler had
to stand representative beler made the
second and uh the motion was made by
representative leus representative leus
do you have to like to speak to your
motion I I
would
um we
heard from the sponsor of this that they
did not believe that
any T New Hampshire tax paay money
should go towards the
support of a charitable
organization that is
Hampshire and from that I could
assume
that that individual does not want any
money in the state of New Hampshire to
go to Planned Parenthood because not
only are they not Incorporated in the
state of New Hampshire point of order
point of order Mr chair I I I got what's
your point of order my point of order is
that is that um it's being implied upon
me that that I am believing of certain
things that I clearly don't believe and
I believe the person making those
implications has tried and failed to do
that in this Committee in the past and I
think that's an abhorent use of U of
committee time and asserting um that are
that are clearly not true thank you
thank you um I'm sorry I implied that in
that case I would have to assume that
you did not mean what you said because
Planned Parenthood is not in repus yes
I'm sorry I don't know I do not want
anybody pointing language towards
anybody on this committee or anybody
outside this committee okay period I'm
sorry I take that back I will point out
however that the state pays for lots of
things that are not Incorporated in New
Hampshire and that
therefore if we are that we should not
pass this
bill pointing at one particular
organization that is not Incorporated in
the state of New Hampshire when there
are many corporations in the state of
New Hampshire which we do pay for thank
you further discussion on on the bill
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair so so the um the the purpose of
this bill um as as I presented when I
introduced it is to provide um improved
transparency and Clarity on um on the
expenses that are that are incurred by
the charitable Foundation that uh runs
the education Freedom account program um
last year we were not successful I think
we're very close at um although um to uh
to move the administration of the
program from a charity to the uh to the
state of New Hampshire through the
Department of Education but I think
absent that uh I don't think it's much
to ask that um that the um that the
charitable nonprofit uh in this case uh
provide a a
transparent uh disclosure uh of um of
their of their uh of their revenues and
their expenses as well as their assets
and liabilities and um and because the
um the contract is not with a um is not
with the um the the U children's
scholarship fund of New Hampshire as as
as um as is often referred to it but is
instead with the children's scholarship
fund Incorporated which is based uh
based out of New York and manages 22
other programs in 19 other states that
um that that it is um it is impossible
to actually cull out the um uh the
revenues and the expenses that's one
part so that's the profit and loss piece
as well as the assets and liabilities
from the um from the charitable the
report of charitable operations that
every 501c3 in the country has to file
on an annual basis with the Internal
Revenue Service it's called the form 990
and um my most recent review of the form
9990 filed by the children's scholarship
fund shows absolutely zero revenues
coming from other governments so coming
from government so so clearly the the
dollars that go to the education Freedom
account program do come from the state
of New Hampshire they come from the
state's educational trust fund it is in
the state budget these are government
dollars and the um the 990 reports zero
and uh you can also see from from
looking at that that that the uh that
the numbers over the years of of uh
charitable
contributions that come from I I I don't
know from where but um have um uh uh
have have not um changed they wiggle
around a little bit but it's 2223
million a year going back um going back
several years but they haven't changed
um despite over the last two years over
$25 million in government funds coming
from the state of New Hampshire uh with
all but 10% of that used for um Ed for
funding educational Freedom accounts so
it doesn't show at least in my review of
this those assets uh coming from the
state of New Hampshire and those
liabilities um um incurred through um
through education Freedom accounts
reported
on what what what every
501c3 um uh every charity needs to do
and so from the standpoint of a public
disclosure public accountability public
transparency uh this is a way of uh of
overcoming uh that making it much more
clear and and you know and honestly New
Hampshire has is one of the states with
the largest number of 501 c3s that
operate in the state it um it it
certainly hasn't presented uh to be an
obstacle with with other nonprofits
incorporating is 503 5050 1 c3s uh in
the state of New Hampshire and um and I
think should we uh should we not be
moving in a direct well I think we
should be moving in a direction of
having the uh the the New Hampshire's um
Department of Education administer the
program but fallowing short of that I
think we should have a New Hampshire
nonprofit administering the program at
least make the 990s clear thank you
thank you very much is our further
discussion represent
Damon thank you Mr chair just want to
remind the committee that while we heard
testimony that suggested that this bill
would somehow interfere
with students receiving their education
Freedom account vouchers the bill does
not in any way change the implementation
of the voucher program it just increases
transparency in the funding of
it represent cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman um I would just like to point
out that um
uh that there is an audit done um and of
the uh scholarship organization that's
available on the website there's much
information available on the website uh
to provide
transparency um there is an oversight
commission uh that did do a report this
year um and actually there was a a
Minority Report uh from uh chairman lad
and myself um to that report um so I I
think that there is
transparency um I I I would like to see
uh for instance um the uh or scholarship
organization does do a a survey of
parents uh for the tax credit
scholarship program um which is the
subject of this um legislation I'd like
to see them do that um for the uh
education Freedom account program also
and I've I've talked to uh the director
um about that um but I I think that
there is transparency
um and the money that they have saved
from the allowable administrative cost
of
10% um does go to additional money for
for students and I believe uh the past
two years um that administrative uh uh
amount has been less than uh
8% thank you uh represent B has hand
then we'll come this
side uh thank you Mr chair I I think
there's really two primary important
points to hit on on this bill um number
one is as it as has previously been
pointed out the state uh does contract
with a number of other NOS um and
organizations that are not Incorporated
in the state but they are nonetheless
registered in in good standing to do
business in the state so the first thing
is the the specific way this bill is
written means it would only apply to one
corporate entity in this state and
because of that I believe this would
meet the legal definition of
discrimination and open us up the
lawsuits which we would likely lose the
second big thing to point out is the
actual practical effect that this bill
would have if it were to go into effect
it would result in the immediate
desertification of the only organization
currently authorized to run our
scholarship and EFA
program as a result the 2,300 New
Hampshire students who were depending on
a dist dispersement from that
organization roughly in September of
this year would not receive it because
there would be no organization from
which to receive it and they would be
forced out of their current educational
circumstances when this fact was brought
up to during our hearings we heard from
some proponents of this bill that we
might expect an amendment to be
forthcoming pushing the deadline to
allow the organization who is currently
running it time to incorporate in New
Hampshire before this would be in effect
today uh further question representative
uh McDonald and then represent Pell
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to
address what was said a moment ago by
representative Damon because I would
agree this bill as written would not
change the implementation of the voucher
program because New Hampshire does not
have a voucher program as it's been said
in this committee what New Hampshire
does have is an education Freedom
account program which is distinctly
different I would however and I do
generally support the concept of
vouchers but that's a
mischaracterization of the program thank
you representative pill Mr chairman
clarify I said education Freedom account
voucher that is still an inaccurate term
but thank you okay we all have gone
through this great discussion before uh
you can believe what you want believe
you can believe what you want to believe
representative petel well representative
McDonald stole my comment
okay um representative Heath then
represent Woodcock thank you Mr chair I
have was not here for the testimony but
to my knowledge all the Secretary of
State um all nonprofit corporations
established under New Hampshire law must
file a nonprofit report every 5 years um
failure to do so could result in um
dissolution I don't understand why I I
am naive I guess in the fact that I
always thought that the scholarship
organization was incorporated and had
filed with the Secretary of State's
office um I thought that was a
requirement and is the Secretary State
aware that this organization doesn't
file with them it is filed
representative cordelli I believe that
they are filed but it's filed as a quote
unquote foreign non profit because it's
um out of state thank you now represent
Woodcock yes thank you ch um I I think I
take a different perspective on this on
this program uh the uh young woman who
was here uh talking uh in testimony
about the program uh indicated that
she'd been uh had exposure to multiple
organizations including initial one as a
501 C3 nonprofit and she's done the
paperwork for that she knows how to do
that uh and I I don't and I think when
she was talking about the fact that when
she first started she was out you know
trying to take out money for the the
scholarship organization which was
terrific um but her annual pay was
$20,000 because she only get the 10% of
the 200 she rise she was really working
how to do that however when I asked her
what the salary account was now she said
over 1
million and I asked her how many
employees she had she said well we moved
to eight
so the salary account and and so I'm
thinking I want by happen stance I
happen to be on two or three different
foundations all of which are uh
nonprofits and they're all run by a
board um so the beauty of that is the
forms that uh this nonprofit requirement
would nonprofit organization would
require delineates through the Board of
Trustees how money's are spent where
they spent um and that's it so I just
see this as a very simp
accounting bill I don't see it as a
prejudicial bill um I think she's done a
heck of a job building that organization
but uh I just think it shows the public
here's where your money goes here's how
it's being used here's what you use for
salaries here's percentage we're taking
and I don't see it as anything wouldn't
that and I think it this this committee
often often ask for transparency in
every single thing we do and
accountability from from any anything we
do so this seems very simple to me this
this allows because as a New Hampshire
nonprofit doesn't sh the paperwork it's
in there there we go I don't see any
more than that I just think I think
we're we're making a mistake by allowing
this to continue without providing any
uh data towards that information repres
thank you represent mil thank you Mr
chair you know this is a simple
bill it's a simple Bill file with the
state you know every time we bring up
efas or tax credits everybody goes
ballistic in trying to protect it we're
dealing with an organization potentially
not the tax credit but uh deal with the
EFA since it was mentioned you're
talking about 60 million dollars
here this is not a simple little bill or
program and every time we try to bring
out some kind of a guard rail that
provides some direction some manage
within the state everybody goes
crazy you know in during the
testimony it was brought out that the
current program is an outlier
now with the with the New York program
that other state organizations are filed
locally with their
state so I I I I wish that at some point
in time we can begin to say that this
program has grown
there are kids that are involved in this
program and all we're trying to we're
not trying to repeal this we're just
trying to say how do we get a little
more Focus for it for the state that's
why I I I don't understand why there's
been so much angst about this it's the
simple process of filing with the state
period thank you thank you is are there
is there any more discussion from the
committee represent aler thank you I
just wanted to make a quick
clarification when it comes to um filing
with the state um this organization is
registered with the state they do file
with the state according to the
Secretary of State they are in good
standing but I believe their tax is
maybe filed through their state where
they are Incorporated but they are
meeting all New Hampshire legal
requirements okay I'd like to go right
now into the uh taking action on on the
motion that's on the floor and the
motion on the floor is
itl and with that Madam clerk would you
please call the role Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative buus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no repres
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative oh sorry
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 n representative Heath you're
sitting beside an individual there where
you're gonna have to have an
this yeah yeah I'll move
OT okay represent represent luno
recognize for a motion thank you very
much Mr chair I'll um move a to pass s
second second we have a motion made uh
on this Bel to OTP by represent luno and
second by representative Miler further
discussion from the makers of the motion
I'm guessing there we could go right to
a vote I would hope so I would very much
hope so we know where this is going
folks so Madam clerk would you please
call role the motion is
OTP Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
yes wow wow I didn't hear that that's
you say
something representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad no 10 y 10 n are there any
other motions to be made on this no okay
all righty so it's a it's a 1010 no
recommend ation vote out of the
committee uh
the uh did you say you were going to do
that yeah he okay and then uh represent
LE is working with represent cordelli on
the
BL yes thank you okay yeah and we're
going to take a break right now uh
everybody has an opportunity to stand up
uh get a drink of water or whatever um
and we'll come back here in about at
five
um
um yeah we can
go9 209 yeah I I just want to make sure
right
e
okay to just uh get us where we are
we're going to jump a few bills and the
quote the clerk sitting to my left your
right we're goinging the solar eclipse
and School holiday bill so put your
glasses
1471 Amy is here par me Amy is here FYI
okay and we will be doing the facilities
Bill Miss Clark right after this one
okay thank
you okay
um got it yeah Senator Pell you
recognize for a motion yes thank you I
move ought to pass on 1471
1470 OTP yes
yes no that's not the amendment no yes
uh and I will offer an amendment to
okay I I'd like to offer Amendment uh
H
second second by represent Damon um Mr
chairman let me walk through and and and
indicate what this amendment does the
amendment keeps section one with no
changes as it was submitted to us as
introduced section two which deals with
excused absences what the amendment does
is as New Hampshire Department of
Education is directed to excuse student
absences from school on April 8
2024 if a student travels to view the
total total solar eclipse so it's a one-
day not a two-day
excuse and it also goes on to say
schools are encouraged to embed total
total solar eclipse activities into
curriculum and instruction consistent
with section three of this act so just
trying to get some planning in terms of
what a solar eclipse is embed it into in
some instruction help kids know some of
the other portions of that bill which is
section three here safety viewing a
total solar eclipse and the the
the the bill has introduced didn't
address this and after the committee's
done research we found this the words
that you see there are verbatim from
NASA and supported by optometrist you
don't want to look at a solar eclipse
prior to during and after without proper
equipment over those eyes or all the
items that's mentioned here in this bill
so we don't want to be uh communicating
with kids and school and to people in
school staff that tell the kids to
observe before and after and during and
after but not telling them any of the
safety that should be associated with it
the other thing this B Amendment does it
takes out the rulle making process the
bill as introduced had a Ru making
process in in fact if we left the ru
making process by the time the rule
making would be done it probably about
about a year after the solar eclipse and
so it just doesn't work that way so
that's been struck from the bill so
that's that's the amendment and this uh
uh takes effect immediately upon passage
and also I might
add that this committee has discussed
this as a total and it's probably
appropriate that this committee submit a
letter to the Department of Education
and Advising them without the the
eclipse coming and perhaps it would be
best that some kind of communication be
made with schools regarding the safety
for children
um in their watching this or are
discussed in class uh we want that done
prior to this eclipse curring the bill
could possibly end up being passed after
the eclipse if you know things happen
the way they normally happen around this
House and Senate so um so that's that's
I'm speaking to the D Amendment only
right
now oh R luno yeah thank you very much
Mr chair and um and you know I think
this amendment does make a lot of does
make substantive changes to the um to
the original bill but but just directing
a question at um at section three I'm no
expert but um but uh where you know I
guess how was the the the safety
language um in section three
developed it
was I have it right here section three
of the
amendment yeah that's the safety stuff
yeah it came directly from NASA I I
thought I had handed that out at the
previous previous meeting I think
everybody has a copy there as a cop I
can't put my hands on okay fantastic
it's all NASA okay
fantastic great thank you you're welcome
rep represent Woodcock thank you
chairman I I I uh support the concept I
just have two questions on the amendment
and and the first is um how are you
going to verify that the student travels
and the second one is how far how far is
going to make a travel for a youngster
to leave school if I go from Berlin over
to arrol can get out for the day I got a
better location to look at it I go from
Conway to the the soccer fields down in
molon borrow I get out of school for a
day and it's the 3:00 event so and I
know there just picky little things I
just uh the solar clipse I I think is
terrific um in terms of in terms of our
doe uh making sure if you recall they
said the commissioner is going to pass
out the6 6,000 uh blue blue glasses as
we saw it'd be terrific in integrating
into the education during the science
curriculum is terrific I do ask some
questions about how you going to verify
particular how far how far you
travel I I would say that's a local
school responsibility to figure out how
they're going to verify well do is
saying it's okay you're down you're out
I'm
just yeah the department yeah the is
directed to excuse the student yeah so
there there and it does say about how
far yeah well see this what what we're
doing right here with this is this is
language which came from the sponsor
initially all we did is chop down okay
two days my question thank you reent H
thank you um in section to the excused
absence I'm just wondering is there an
assumption that if teachers want to take
the time off that they're going to have
to go through their bargaining whatever
you know whether they have to take a
personal day I know like our school
district has a I believe used to anyway
had a limit of seven teachers on any
given day beyond that they weren't
required to um would be an assump that
would be an assumption because the bill
doesn't speak to that it speaks to a
student okay doesn't speak to the
faculty okay so I am concerned about
that that the kids can go but the
teachers
can't repr
tner thank you and and I guess I just go
back to my initial comment when we were
talking about it during the committee
testimony and it's why why should we go
through the bill procedure all the paper
everything that that is concerned with
with bills when this can just be a
memorandum to the Department of
Education um I you know why does the
Department of Education have to direct
to excuse student absences when that's
that's a local issue um and you know
that could be in the memorandum that
they strongly suggest that that the
absences are excused but
I can't imagine the school would not
excuse those absences I mean they they
excuse absences for leaving early to go
to you know to to Disney World so um I I
just think we have so many bills I mean
look at this book and look at the book
that we had before that was twice the
size and it's like why are we why are we
making another regulation or another
bill or another law U for something that
really isn't needed that that's just my
representative
cascaden thank you um I agree in the
sense that I don't think we should be
making a law to amend a school
calendar I think it's a wonderful
learning opportunity for students and
there is no doubt that when if schools
are in session they're going to use that
day for some education not all schools
are open several including the Upper
Valley hover Lebanon masoma they're all
closed for spring break maybe
intentionally um schools in the North
country are all closed I've already seen
on sa 84 website a whole public link on
the solar eclipse and different
opportunities for education but what
really makes me say it doesn't belong
here is the process of setting a School
District
calendar though it is individual by
districts districts use use a
recommended suggestion calendar that is
first put out by the department of Ed
and then the districts review it and
then they amend it based on what they
you know their days are the what
required days there are for from their
collective bargaining
agreement and when neighboring schools
are taking spring breaks winter breaks
days off versus not days
off and so I looked at that calendar
that was issued to the districts last
spring and April 8th was not a
recommended day to
close was it an afterthought maybe um
but everybody has already passed their
calendars and I think if they want to do
something locally they have that
Authority I believe with their school
board and then you just have to let the
state know whether you've amended your
calendar but they're not telling you
you're deciding locally so because that
suggested calendar came out and it
didn't recommend by the doe to take
April 8th as a closed day I don't see
why we're backtracking and now telling
them that it should be a law and I mean
if this ends up passing the minimum they
ought to do is at least Supply every
district and student with
classes further further questions uh
represent dry thank you Mr chairman um
could I just ask representative cascad
um if they closed that took that day
that wasn't originally on their calendar
they have to make it up somewhere
else it depends on what their total
instructional hours are because now you
need to be in school 180 days but if the
number of hours of instructional time
that you have built into your full
year um you may not have to make it up I
mean it's like a snow day you know if
you're is a little longer and you've
added 15 minutes to your instructional
time in your school
calendar um then you can look at either
one so every District's different yep
repon
Damon thank you Mr chair I just want to
remind the committee that the amendment
is what's on the table and the amendment
does not talk about closing school and I
think the amendment does make it a
better Bill also because it removes the
rulemaking process
Ron
leus he said put your glasses on so I
put my glasses on
um I wanted to comment on the yes it
doesn't close it doesn't mandate closing
schools but there are schools who have
very
narrow
um
excused absent policies and they give
nonacademic
failures for things that we would think
should be excused like certainly going
to Disney World early would not be
excused in these schools and so by
having us say yes you will excuse this
one allows kids particularly from my
part of the state to be able to go up
and see this thing that's going to
lifetime further discussion
representative
Pell and to not to belabor that point in
particular but I think it also my point
will tie in with what representative
Woodcock said how do you know the
student will travel that day or how do
you verify that they traveled but this
would give parents the opportunity to uh
be honest about what they're doing that
day instead of to say my kid has a
headache represent Bon thank you Mr
chair um I was just going to add I agree
with what um representative Tanner said
in terms of uh issuing a memorandum from
the Department of Education and to the
other question that you had about the
required number of days I believe um a a
school district can apply for a waiver
for a specific purpose and it has come
up before when we had excessive snow
days and the and the State can provide a
waiver yeah I can
remember as a kid when King George
died and I was a school kid in Canada at
the time the doors were locked and and
there was no notice it it was a day off
and kids got credit for school I can
also remember when the Twin Towers went
down in the state I was in and we had
students all over the state and the only
way we could get them back was by
playing but all planes were grounded and
so the day was called off by the
superintendent in the keenai peninsula
no school you know the next day until we
could figure out where all our kids were
so there are there are processes for
waivers that can be given by the
department the commissioner can make
those decisions so um this amendment was
put forth in in support of that bill I'm
not NE I'm not an author of that bill
and I have no ownership on that bill
bill and I do support what represent
Tanner is also saying that I believe a
letter directed from the committee here
trying to emphasize some of the points
in it and let the department send that
technical Bolton out to the districts
the way they normally do on so many
issues I think that's another good tact
we we got to do
something represent Tanner so as a
question chairman lad what would what
would I or anybody do to change to with
we make an amendment to to this bill
that it is a a memorandum that it would
be uh how how would we go about or do we
have to or can we just the way it's been
done in the past is that I always
reflect back in what we did with
representative guile and I've done it
before too you vote the bill down but
then you also as a committee take action
to say we'd like to have this letter
written on our behalf to the Department
and we usually got unanimous consent on
that everybody you know we got a show
and you so the chairman wrote that
letter shared it with all the committee
members and the communication was made
in a timely manner and time for us to
communicate to them on this whole
situation the way it was introduced to
us I was concerned about the liability
the school districts were putting
themselves into and the department was
putting themselves into by saying to the
kids go out and look at it before during
and after and so it comes back and say
well I lost my my retina or whatever I'm
not because of you know your directed to
go out and look at it uh so I I think
that was there's an issue here and I'm
kind betwix and between how to do
this we can send rep leas to all the
schools with with those classes I
thought they were passing them out to
every single kid that's she get mileage
you get yeah okay I I don't know if they
had an ample glasses for that I thought
it was like onethird of what was needed
but representative p no no I was just
going to speak to that be because that
was off mic but um I believe the bill
sponsor said that a significant amount
of glasses were going to be distributed
to the schools in the state from the do
yeah it was yeah it was a I thought
there was a quantity that was matched to
was it 50 or 60,000
she said
160 160 so every 160,000 but one of the
following testimony people say very high
to access uh the availability of them so
yeah okay further discussion on this
Bill yes excuse me on the on the
amendment sorry yeah I'm just I'm rather
confused I think we all agree on what
needs to be done I think I I'll speak
for myself I guess
I you know kids should be seeing the
eclipse if at all possible teachers
should be seeing it uh you know you
should not have two school days for it
no I don't think you need this at all I
mean I think a memo from the state
department from the Department of Ed so
I guess my question is so how do we do
that who knows the answer to that
without doing this represent wock just
vote it down and is it possible um for
this to be set on your executive
schedule table and have director here to
write a letter on behalf of the
committee what was the first part table
this in the schedule until another well
we we just we wouldn't take action on it
right now I'll take
action you write a letter on behalf of
the committee in the interim it is a
bill that's not an early
bill there's apparently no fiscal note
to
it so we'd have to take action on this
by the middle of March up or
down
well if postponing it if you postpone
this to March the eclipse is in what
April and if you what I think if you're
going to do anything for with the
Department it ought be done
now the gear up for this and and who
knows they may be already I don't know
uh but yes rer I think one of the things
that we could do um is um is vote this
down and then direct the chair on the
record to send that letter of request to
the department uh for a technical
advisory to send out to the schools I
mean that that would be one of the
procedures that we could do correct
that's a procedure yes thank you there's
another procedure too that the maker of
motion I'm not not no you made you made
the motion represent Pell for OTP I made
the motion for Amendment so what I will
do is I don't know who second the
amendment so I will pull that you two so
we don't have that Amendment on the on
the table right now as a motion so it's
just sitting there in your packet so now
we're back to the original motion of
OTP but the bunch of us like
the oh yeah if we're going to have the
bill I I like that too but you know I
think we're headed towards another way
of dealing with
Administration you st let's do it let's
do a straw pool which is not taking
action on it so how many people right
now on the committee listen up how many
people would like to in uh itl this bill
and then to have a motion a letter sent
department how many the other
way so we're talking about 1 2 3 4 to 16
to four that's what we got four five
five six you're saying up too so we're
basically 14 to six yeah four to six no
put your hands up those that are
are that are not supportive going with
the amendment and going with the
bill going with the amend can I say can
I say something to that because I would
only support the amendment I would not
support the original Bill and see
exactly where I am too you'd have to
bring the amendment
back
so so okay we just vote on the amendment
no no no there is no Amendment right now
and I'm not putting the amendment
forward are there any other amendments
on this bill can somebody else put this
forward yeah sure anybody Put It Forward
if you're on a sitting member on the
committee I would like to move the
amendment we're going right back where
we were I think we should vote on it you
pulled it did you officially pull it yes
I I I I withdrew
okay hey guys this is going crazy yeah
this is like like sack right pardon me
this makes for good
TV
LE okay so we have a motion on the floor
for the
amendment not having any further
discussion on it we'll have we'll call
amendment Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
no no no I put you down for no okay uh
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
Representative albone no Representative
cascaden no representative
Damon no chairman lad yes 10 y 10 10 so
the motion does not
pass okay so we're now to the main
Bill
OTP the motion made by represent
Bill did you want to speak to well can I
withdraw
OTP or
is do anything yeah yeah yeah can I
withdraw the motion we had subsequent
motions on on that uh no I think we're
at the point where we're going to vote
up or down yeah right yeah we're we're
going to we got a motion on the table
OTP that's where we have to pick it up
uh so against just vote against it if
you're just because you put a motion for
it doesn't mean you have to vote on
it can we speak to
exactly why because of the safety
concerns that are not addressed in the
original bill so I just want to make
sure that that's apparent before I vote
against my own motion we're gonna have
further we're gonna have we're gonna
have further committee discussion on the
bill right now because you've already
you
know you've already had your opportunity
to speak on OTP prior to the amendment
being offered so that's done so you
don't have to worry about that so now
where we are as we're on this motion
OTP it's open to discussion amongst the
committee anybody want to speak to
it the bill itself represent pel thank
you I originally moved a to pass because
I was in favor of the amendment but the
bill as written um doesn't take some
significant safety concerns into
consideration so I will actually be
voting against a to pass on the original
Bill further discussion refer beler
thank you Mr chair and I and I totally
respect that view and the opinion of rep
petal I would note however that there
already existing um safety guidelines
that are being published by the federal
government we have been told that
sunglasses will be handed out um in
schools and they will receive um
instructions on them and I also believe
in the in the private Marketplace that
there's going to be ample education from
news media and other sources on the on
the risk so I I would say that that is
not um not a big concern for me
personally thank you representer
cascaden just want to reiterate again
that the department of Ed did not
suggest April 8th as a day to be
closed and I'd like to interject one
thing now we're voting on a bill that
has rule making in it the ru making is
going to kill this thing anyways because
not going to not going to occur before
the eclipse so that's what you're voting
on represent
Cordell thank you Mr chair um so um I
got the eclipse guys coming to my
library for a presentation now they're
they were great and I'm going to have to
explain to them why I voted against
their bill so I just want to go on the
record with um that this doesn't in any
way take away from how important I think
this is but I'm also believer in the
fact that we have way too many laws and
I know this one's just going to
go out it won't you know last it's um
but uh considering that and that I feel
like the discussion here there there's
another way of doing this of making this
happen of allowing the students to see
this and not be um considered absent
that I I would
uh vote against OTP myself further
discussion represent Damon thank you Mr
chair I just want to note in case other
folks have not seen this that the
sponsor of the bill just sent us a
message um in which she says she's
watching us and it was mentioned to
Simply quote encourage the commissioner
to do this administratively she reminds
us that's exactly what she did she
originally approached the commissioner
on this matter and he insisted that he
needed legislation to accomplish this
and then she notes this bill is
introduced as virtually word for word
the same as what he tasked the job to be
I just paraphrase
slightly that that said I uh will be
voting against the
OTP further
discussion BR
Ford are we not simply author your mic
is not on are we not simply authorizing
the schools to do that is that the
purpose to the
bill yes
so the schools can legally say this is
legal to do and they don't have to argue
that
question I would argue from the
perspective that if the Red Sox were
playing in penway park in the last game
of the World Series how many kids would
be down
there and would they get an excused
absent socks than well so what that's
represent
Tanner thank you I I think all the
objections that that people have raised
certainly can be incorporated into that
uh memo to the Department of Education
to suggest that it's an excused absence
to have the safety issues in there I I
just again think we can achieve what I
think everybody here wants to achieve is
to make the solar eclipse an important
event a very important event to make
sure that it's done in a safe Manner and
that kids get the opportunity to um if
their parents take them someplace to get
an excused absence
representative
uh no I'll go representative McDonald
first all right thank you um just a
question for the chair the letter that
we've discussed and seemed to be in
agreement on is that still possible at
this moment sure okay yep that would be
a result of what type of action we take
here today and that's the way we have
done it before on certain issues where
there's been communication on behalf of
this whole committee sent to the
Department
then with respect could I ask you to
call the question on the vote if we're
all decided how we're going to vote
anyway is there anybody opposed to that
perspective because we' never closed
down discussion in committees like that
we'll have one quick comment here is it
okay yes sorry about that that's okay
just wanted to check um just I I think
if the commissioner was saying that um
legislation was needed it is
due to what's in line six and seven in
that it directs the department to wave
compulsory School attendance I think if
that's in there that's why the
needed but the commissioner also told me
that um he did not know um about April
9th being included in the
legislation you warmed up representative
cascaden just want to reiterate that the
department of Ed issues a recommended
calendar they did not recommend Monday
April 8th as a closed day okay who's in
charge of
that okay we have a motion on table and
motion is
1471 Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative beler yes
representative dry no representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell no I'm sorry oh okay representative
Pell
no representative Court tiell no
representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no represent representative Balon
no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
no uh three Ys 17 Nays is there any
consent and I'd like to take a straw
vote on right now of the committee
should the chair write a letter to the
department with the concerns that we've
addressed in our discussion here
much yeah yeah so now we're not done
that we're not done that because the
motion was
OTP so is there a motion that's going to
be coming forward here uh represent
Tanner yes I'd like to put forth the
motion itl is there a second to that
that's on the opposite
party do you want to second that motion
representative
Ford great okay so we have a motion made
by Tanner second by representative
Ford speak to your motion uh just that
this motion is in place so that we can
uh then move on to a a technical
advisory from the doe thank you further
discussion Madam clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
belter
yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald
no representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes yes representative Coro yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y one a okay so I was mistaken
because last vote was 16 the three
that's not what goes in the calendar I
goes in the calendar 19 to1 and all good
with consent yes okay so the motion is
itl with the letter we did by straw
vote okay thank you it's now
12:25 we still have some bills which we
Haven an exact um what we'll do
herec no let's do the facility so so we
can get Amy out of
here people are here for the food bill
and the food bill too yeah we're schedu
to start the other at
1:45 so got we got time here Mr chair
yes on the um on the facilities bill um
did we discuss that maybe another some
language was necessary
procedurally well yeah I I've discussed
the issue that we discussed in there and
we're going to be discussing that uh
when we introduce this bill and having
the department gotcha okay thank you so
I'd like to have 1165 this is procedures
for school
facilities um and we do have an
amendment on
that um but before we go with any of
that I'd like to have a
discussion on on this bill there is an
amendment I'd like everybody to look at
that
five and Miss Clark If you have a second
would you come up but we have a couple
questions ask you not so much on the
changes in the amendment but a change
that's in part six dealing with the
public school infrastructure
fund and it's where we it
reads this is the part that's deleted it
reads the first meeting of the
commission shall be called by the first
named House member that's typical
language in setting up any commission
you know it's called by the first uh
representative if it's a house bill and
then the commission elects a chairman at
that orientation meeting or the first
meeting the deleted areic goes on the
first meeting of the commission shall be
held within 45 days of the effective
date of this section the commission
shall meet at least monthly I understand
that that the latter part meeting
monthly we we we get that we know that
that's upon the need but the question we
have is that what happens if in terms of
the public school infrastructure
commission I have been that chair of
that commission ever since its
beginning what happens if I leave for
some
reason it could be anybody then who
calls the next
meeting uh representative lad that's a
good question I don't know if I could
get a copy of the amendment that would
be great but um in general I know the
law that law fairly well so I think I
know what you're talking about I would
have to take a read it over and and
happen are there any question we're
talking about this particular area right
here the other areas where we Chang the
definition of the the project manager
we we understand where you're coming
from there it's owner's project manager
we're good with that at least I am I
think that every everybody's good with
that we're just concerned about this one
small area which is really not really a
a huge impact
but it's more of a
procedural
[Music]
issue or whether it should be the first
part of that part that's deleted should
not be deleted in the last sentence
needs to be deleted where requiring of
the monthly meeting I'm reading this
here real quickly that that makes sense
I think the concern from the commission
was simply that they were required to
meet monthly and at certain periods of
the year there's not no action for them
to do so the focus really was uh
removing that sentence that you
mentioned and I believe the a prior
sentence which is uh the prior two
sentences that you're referring to I
think the intent was just that that was
uh past language it wasn't needed I
don't think there's any if you wanted to
keep it that's fine I don't think there
was any purpose for deleting it other
than cleaning it up so that makes sense
yeah so in in hearing that and of course
represent Heath you're on that
commission as well and I think the
commission's been together so long we
think that's going to go on into forever
and obviously it won't uh although the
funding has been very generous we have
the $10 million right now and it's over
$50 million that commission has had so
perhaps what it's best for us to do
right now is to skip over this bill get
an amendment made to keep those first
sentences in place and to delete the
portion where you were required to meet
monthly right now we're at a kind of a
reprieve because we've had the money
been you know we're already in that
process and there's no need to meet
monthly uh until we we have to start
reviewing those applications to come in
from Homeland
Security so are there any other areas
within this technical changes above that
your rep Cornell the this wasn't in the
bill but I think the representative from
the contractors was concerned because on
the department website it only listed
four recommended and that that was a
problem cuz cuz he said people were
looking at it thinking those were the
only
four Yes actually right after that
meeting we went and we updated our
website and put a little paragraph
clarifying that those are the um that
they're not the only ones there thank
you
y so are there any other issues
associated with that Amendment we could
get another amendment put together and
eliminate because I want if they're not
I'm going to let you know mcart go back
to Doe and get on with her job over
there there's no sense for her to hang
around till we act on this later on
today when we get a new
Amendment yeah uh just a clarification
on um those crossed out
lines that you need to put back in the
first meeting of the commission shall be
called by the first named House member
and then I thought I heard you say the
last
the uh the not the next can't even speak
the line after the next one that says
the commission shall meet at least
monthly and I thought I heard um Amy say
that some months they don't have any
business so does that have to be worded
rewarded so that the commission it's
just deleted it's going to be deleted I
wasn't sure you were so that's where we'
be and that that's been we've talked
commission represent Woodcock thank CH
just to be clear when you come back with
the revised Amendment you you're still
going to leave the preschool piece in
there right the what part preschool line
21 you're not changing that nothing I
don't when you bring back the new we're
only looking for the one section that
we've been just addressing now to change
everything else remains in place as
presented in the amend by the department
in the amendment thank you represent
Damon thank you I just want to say I
greatly appreciate the language of the
last four lines addressing the air
quality discussion that we had and okay
we we will be having further discussion
this thing but I think Amy you're off
the hook that we know where we're going
with this and appreciate it thank you
you're waiting for that I have another
bail at 145 but I appreciate you
squeezing me in before lunch okay so
we're not going to take action on that
now we're going to just get an amendment
made and we got to now trip to 1212
which is eligibility for free School
meals so we can let the other group
loose too
for
uh eligibility for free School meals we
have representa beler do you want make
motion on that yes Mr chair I would move
um in expedient to
legislate is a second second Is there
further
discussion from the maker of the
motion yes Mr chair thank you um so what
what this bill would do is it would it
would increase the threshold for
providing free and reduced U meals and
schools from the current federal
guidelines of it's about about 180% of
federal poverty level and it would
increase it to
350% of federal poverty level um however
unlike the the current situation where
the state is reimbursed for these um
expenditures this would be entirely out
of state coffers um and out of the uh
New Hampshire taxpayer funds now the
fiscal note we have on this demonstrates
that this uh is estimated to run more
than $50 million per year with more than
or about a half a million of that being
oversight of this particular program and
with all of that it is very important to
note that even though this money is
coming from the New Hampshire taxpayer
for this program the New Hampshire ta
tax payer and us as their
representatives have very little ability
to affect the expenditures of these
funds because it ties the funding to the
existing Federal USDA program meaning
that we would have to follow all federal
guidelines from everything from
nutrition to bidding process and
everything else on these funds um and I
do not believe that is a that's a wise
use of new taxpayer funds I believe if
we are to Institute any sort of expanded
program like that it is something that
New Hampshire is paying for and we
should totally control it from top to
bottom thank
you okay uh there was a sheet do does
this make of the second one this discuss
already want to get into this sheet
right here which came
around uh we have this sheet that was
handed to us I don't think you can read
that from there but you can unlike the
borrow your eyes
um they copies do you have copies of
this
okay could could this be walked through
explained um good afternoon um that
Kelly Rambo from the Department of
Education Bureau administrator for
wellness and nutrition I'm mam Marshall
um administrator for the office of
services so I believe that we had sent
two
um two follow-up documents to um when we
were here last and um
the one that has two charts on it or it
looks
like yes yes yeah this one yes um so
this one that's in front of
you um when we came last um we gave the
number that if all students in the state
of New Hampshire were to get meals all
enrolled students in the state of New
Hampshire and schools um and from that
feedback what we thought might be
helpful to see is actual um School meals
that were served for the school year
2223 so that you can see a comparison of
the if all children and students were to
eat what the cost would be versus what
actual meals were served at the local
level and what the cost was for that for
2022 to
2023 so that's what that um that chart
is if you turn are there any any
questions on that chart from the from
the committee Damon thank you
um I may be very confused so please help
me understand this this is the side of
the page you're referring to correct yes
the title should be 2223 data with
FY Federal reimbursement y 24 Federal
reimbursement okay so we're looking at
the same
thing
Isen please again the difference between
the top and the bottom because the
titles are all exactly the same sure so
the top half is the based on
eligibility and those students that are
enrolled in school for 2223 so that's
um an average of let's just say 160,000
students in the state of New Hampshire
that are enrolled in schools that's the
number that's on the top chart when you
go down to the bottom chart what we did
was we took the actual meals that were
served last school year and applied that
number to actual meals that are being
served so we know that um although the
top number is is what we've given you as
a um let's say it's the maximum amount
that it could cost
we thought it might be helpful to see
when you actually break it down and
apply to actual meals being served in
the school what that number looks like
may I follow up
yes so just to verify what I'm
understanding from you the top number is
what it would be if we were feeding both
breakfast and lunch to all public school
students is that correct correct and the
bottom number is what we actually are
doing currently or last year last year
um so that is the students who qualify
under the existing free and reduced
meals that was from free and reduced
numbers from last year because that's
the yes that's the data that we or 185%
correct thank you very much and just
follow so the cost to the state on the
top table
there if if uh all kids were receiving
would be 122 or $123
million that's correct and that's with
the federal reimbursement being applied
to that as well too so if the state were
to operate outside of the USDA um
operations and um not take the
reimbursement from the federal
government that number would be
significantly higher and we can um get
those numbers for you if it's something
that you'd like to to
see so th this number 120 three round
rounding it off million that includes
the federal dollars that's correct what
would it be if those federal dollars
were not what what are we putting in
there to make this total come up to 122
we can get that number for you we don't
okay further questions yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair can you also
get us a number two
numbers um for all those students the
top
160,000 if it's only breakfast or only
lunch because the bill does not require
both meals it requires
one sure so um if you follow the the
chart from um from left to right you can
see that free breakfast would cost
obviously there would be no cost to the
state because that reimbursement would
come from the federal government if you
um follow the chart to say reduced
breakfast there are currently um
69 average students um and the state is
already currently paying that portion
and that amount um so we can break it
down um outside of this chart if you
would like um further though pretty
accurate
though further questions yes
representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your technical support I just wanted
to um because it was brought up that
this does not require um schools to
provide both breakfast and lunch and I I
would strictly agree with that but would
you agree that this bill enables local
schools to decide that they will provide
both meals for free because it says each
School Board shall make at least one
meal available during this the school
hours to every people under his
jurisdiction so that's existing language
but this raising that threshold and
promising to fund it from the New
Hampshire taxpayer um would it be
reasonable to conclude that many schools
both yes um however the as the the bill
reads um it's only one um identifying
one meal for them um that they shall
provide
that at least yeah at least yeah further
question representative
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm still
confused about this and you know it's
it's new all new stuff to me uh you
mentioned another level of decision by
the state I don't understand what else
there is they decide you said if said
they should decide
to sure um thank you for the question um
just for clarification if the state
entity as a whole were to decide to not
participate in the federal the USDA
Federal Child Nutrition program um
that's what I meant by if the state were
to decide to to go outside of the
program and not elect to follow those
guidelines they would not be eligible to
receive the federal reimbursement that
comes with that okay thank you represent
Bon thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um just
to go back to the two charts again they
both include
all students so if I look at the bottom
chart it's it's every student then that
program so the top the top chart is for
those that are enrolled in public school
currently so um not every single student
does partake in the program but the
bottom chart does indicate the meals
that we're sered that were part of the
program from last school year so yes
that's correct okay and just a follow up
to to that so it it in no way indicates
in the second chart down here what it
would be if the uh threshold was risen
to
350% that's correct we don't have that
we we don't have that data currently
okay repr cascad thank you Mr chair um
just want to add to the committee since
we were talking about feeding kids um
recently the New Hampshire food bank has
recognized that there is an underserved
region in the state and are expanding um
their services to the North country
because it experiences the highest rate
of food insecurity that was last
week's um information with 10.2% of the
residents and
14.9% of children are experence
experiencing hunger every
day now we wouldn't need this bill if
they were fed where they should be fed
but because they're not
how can you deny kids a hot meal every
day so that they can learn in a more
appropriate state of
mind just data that was in the newspaper
and just wanted to share that thank you
for that sorry Hall thank you Mr chair
um so this bill mirror is a bill from
last year um House Bill 572 which passed
in this committee
it passed in the Full House and that was
300% so this one raises it to 350 but
all the other language is the same
except for the um effective date um so
it passed you know we have to feed kids
kids can't go to school hungry or they
do they do go to school hungry and I I
don't think we can sit back and do
nothing about that uh we heard over half
of New Hampshire children live in
households that have insufficient food
half half of our kids School meals play
a critical role in their health Wellness
uh academic
success um this bill would alleviate
food insecurity it helps support good
nutrition and you know we give kids
computers we give kids books we give
them the tools for learning but an
essential part of living is being fed so
uh it's a basic necessity of Life uh
last year on this bill one of the Big
stumbly Blocks I felt was it never went
to finance it wasn't even though it had
a fiscal note there nothing there it
never went to finance so that was always
a stumbling block yeah but Finance
hasn't seen it well this year it is an
early Bill and and it should go to
finance so I would strongly urge you to
support this the least we can do are
there any further questions to the
department regarding the these sheets
right here because we will have that
discussion represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
again I wanted to De delve a little
deeper into your response um when it
came to what you said the federal
government would do if we went outside
the USDA program you said they would
they would suspend all funding so I so I
just want to clarify and ask you is it
is it fair to say then that the federal
government is going would prevent the
state of New Hampshire from developing
our own food nutrition program providing
these schools using New Hampshire
taxpayer dollars on our own guidelines
under threat of cutting all federal
funding for School meals thank you for
the question um just to I guess rephrase
my um answer from before it was that if
the state chose to not use the
guidelines um and wanted to do something
else that they that there obviously are
certain parameters and guidelines in
order to be able to get the funding um
and and that was kind of the basis of
the question um excuse me of of my
answer for for
that so just trying to get a little
definition the bottom figure here your $
34.7
million is that money that's coming out
that so um the $34 million that is on
the bottom there um no um if you can see
that the total cost for um that the
state is currently paying right now
which is the
$269,000 that currently is coming out of
that um because that's what the is in
statute and the state pays for the
reduced price breakfast um for those
kiddos that um so that they don't have
to pay that price and what um the the
one above that was um just for
convenience um to the reduced price
lunges if that were to be included um in
in that as well too which is currently
not being paid by the
state you you in 296,000 you're talking
right yes 296,000 is currently being
paid by the state correct for the
reduced price
breakfast okay and that's at
300% no that's at 185% 185 so correct
reduced I'm trying to find out what
we're how much the state is actually
having to pay to sustain the program
that's being requested that's what I'm
trying to drive at and unfortunately
without having the data of those
families that would qualify
for um the 186 to
350 we can't give you that exact number
um which is why we had given the
original 122 million so that you could
see if all enrolled students um it it
very well could be less than that um but
that's that's the number that we were
with the data that we have um also on
the back end it looks like on
everybody's page um we did provide some
additional data um back to
201819 on meal served so that you could
see um and um Amanda oh I do have it
um and so so this does break it this
does break it down um what the total
reimbursements um for the state were and
again this is actual meal served from
2020 to 21 you can see that um the
heading there is meals were at no cost
learning on the other side you can see
that 21 to 22 meals were still at no
cost to students as the federal
government was paying for those then um
but that was back to in-person learning
and then the last chart on the bottom is
2223 and that's with in-person learning
and back to being charged by free
reduced and paid and the federal
government was not subsidizing the total
cost of meals for um students so we just
wanted to give a um kind of
overarching um I know it's a lot of
numbers and I I know it's um um somewhat
daunting so um please if there uh are
any additional questions even after this
um we'll be happy to answer them Celli
thank you um thank you for sticking
around today um on the um the line that
the chairman was referring to the two
$296,000
plus um it says the state is currently
paying reduced breakfast amount
therefore the total additional cost to
state to the cover the reduced excuse me
they're they're paying the reduced
breakfast
amount is this the 296 is that the total
paid for the reduced breakfast amount or
is that the total to cover the
additional uh cost of reduced
lunch that's the um the total to for the
for the the um the lunch that's the
additional portion for the lunch if you
go to the top um and follow from left to
right the reduced breakfast price you'll
see that
98,000 is currently what's being paid by
the state um what was paid by the state
last year for for the breakfast if I can
follow up yes so then um to get the
state payment for reduced breakfast and
reduced lunch you'd add the 296 and the
98 correct to get the 395 that it's
right above that gotcha okay okay other
further questions represent
leus thank you for taking my question um
I want to make sure I understand on that
second chart where it says paid lunch
um 30
million that was paid by the students is
that correct that is correct that is
correct thank
you are there any other questions for
the Department yes represent luno sure
thank thank you very much Mr chair and
and and thanks m m Rambo um I I think
this question's been asked before I'm
sure it's been asked before but I'm just
a little thick uh this afternoon so the
$122
state let me ask you another one what's
the $122 million sure thank you for the
question um so the $122 million would be
um if I can rephrase it that if the
state were to pay for Universal meals
for all students enrolled um in the
state of New Hampshire that would be the
cost to the state
with the federal reimbursement already
take it into consideration after Federal
reimbursement correct after Federal
reimb follow up Mr chair yeah so if
we're talking about a program that would
would cover meals for um 0 to
350% of the federal poverty level and we
know that
350% is a little bit above the the mean
um household income uh in New Hampshire
so between 50 and
60% of of households would be inside of
that
350 that I know this is a little bit
engineering finger in the wind but but
the total cost for 350 per for the
program up to 350% would be about
between yeah 50 or 60% of that 122
million yes in the fiscal note we did
make that calculation that is about 60 %
of the students in the 160,000 students
in New Hampshire could potentially cost
about $75 million okay thank you very
much represent
Pell thank you I have a question that's
not related to these sheets specifically
but it is for the Department is that
okay all right so I I just um wanted to
ask if you could clarify um the
difference between food insufficiency
and food security and the reason I ask
is because on New Hampshire hunger
Solutions website um and I know it's not
the department website they have some
interesting data and they have uh I'm
not sure how they did this survey um but
the categories are enough food but not
always the kinds wanted and often not
enough to eat sometimes not enough to
eat did not report level and
than the total quantity of all of the
other three and in households with
children out of 164,000 respondents
9,957 said they had enough food but not
always the kind they wanted and then
often not enough eat was
16,000 sometimes not enough to eat is um
basically
19,000 and did not report the level
is about 38,000 and then I do have a
followup thank you for the question um
unfortunately I'm not familiar with that
survey that has been done um and I would
have to since it's not our data I'd have
to inquire with Hunger Solutions um and
unfortunately I I can't answer that
question right
now but can you define the difference
between um food insufficiency and
insecurity please um I'd have to get
back to you on that related to to the
survey and what they they were asking
on you typically do you typically work
with insecurity is is that how the
department goes by their data or do you
not look into that at all you just go by
the Numbers we don't we rely on the free
and reduced numbers okay um can I ask
one more question please um is there
anything that would prevent a local
community from donating money to um
support students who needed
um more food in the school so it would
it be possible to say donate money and
say can you give this to the student who
owes the most money right now for um
their reduced lunch that they couldn't
pay without identifying student
information um could you um do have
regular fundraisers to send more money
to the school so could the local schools
incorporate this
350% on their own without this
legislation
thank you for the question um so there
is the capability um since it is local
control for the schools to be able to do
that they should have a a policy um in
place for um donations or something of
that kind so there is that capability
and that would be a local level control
for
that other questions on the technical
stuff here from the Department because
yes
yes isn't isn't the um free and reduced
lunch
um statistics based or a basis for kind
of quas what the what the community's um
is thank you for that question um that
is outside of my office um and
unfortunately I cannot answer that
question okay if if it if it was I would
think that the community would not be
totally in a position to donate enough
money to then fund all the kids that
that's my point okay we're we're getting
a little bit beyond the pale here in
terms of the technical support I want to
thank we're we're really we
got a number of issues coming up before
us today we haven't had lunch yet it's
1:00 we got to be back at
1:45 if it's very specific about the
numbers go ahead represent Damon thank
you very much Mr chair and I do want to
note the irony that we're talking about
feeding hungry kids while we are all
sitting here
hungry on a shortterm level so my
question is on the enlarg page that you
handed out the 2021 2022 data when we
returned to in-person learning but meals
were still at no
cost how who were the students who were
getting those meals was that Universal
meals or was that x% of
thank you for the question so that was
Universal meals um and just the the
terminology um that we are using meals
at no cost um so that it doesn't get
confused with the the free reduced
status um so that's the the terminology
for meals at no cost thank you very much
and represent
LE thank you so looking at numbers there
are numbers or kids or something missing
as in we we have the total amount that
was paid and then if all kids were and
in and in this one as well we ended up
with 86 million as opposed to 122 so is
that difference either kids who aren't
eating lunch or kids who are bringing
lunch so is bringing lunch why there's a
difference thank you for the question so
yes the the top number on um the with
two of them is that if all students were
to eat meals at school and be provided a
meal at school and not bring a bagged
lunch um the other chart that um Amanda
handed out is the actual meals that were
served to those students that ate at
school not not the the um the brown bag
or or other lunches that were um brought
gonna
represent Woodcock go for it but that
this is the last
question thank you um on the expanded
chart on the fall off the represent D on
expanded chart of the return to
inpersonal learning the total cost was
right and 2223 on the shot the other
side we got today visual slide one you
have that would be in today's prices
that would be 122 million so we've gone
up almost $40 million in a year for the
cost is that of the
meal so the one with the four charts
those were the actual meals served so
the 86 million was what the federal kind
of reimbursements and all the
reimbursements end of the day the actual
meal served the top chart is just all of
the students that are enrolled in the
schools if they eat both breakfast and
lunch for the 180 days of the school
year thank you thank you thank you very
much and thank you to just to to follow
up on that the reason we wanted to show
you the um the second chart with the
actual meal served at no cost is to show
that um the difference between if
students were to pay for their meals and
you can see that um it is a significant
amount higher if the meals are at no
cost to them and there are additional
students eating so we just wanted to
give those comparison um numbers and
that thank you very much for spending
the time with us today appreciate
it um what we're going to do is we're
going to take a break right now
um I think we've gone beyond the pale on
on a lot of things here um we do still
have some exact sessions that take place
pardon me
and we're taking a break right now we'll
come back to this executive session
we'll continue following the hearings
this afternoon Mr chairman yes could we
do a caucus during
lunch because we've I think people have
to get lunch so we we we've had if we
need to do a caucus we'll do a caucus
later when we're into the
bill that you may want a caucus
for thank you very much so we'll take a
break start back up at
1:45 um we're not doing any exec after
to
good
afternoon we'll try and get started uh
somewhat on
schedule um after a busy
morning um and the first bill uh for the
afternoon docket is House Bill 1161
relative to the use of public school
infrastructure fund for energy efficient
buses and um chairman lad is here to
bill Mr chairman and members of the
education for the record my name is Rick
lad I represent hail New Hampshire and
I'm here today to introduce HB
1161 uh this is a bill relative to
public school infrastructure fund uh for
energy efficient school
buses
um just a brief background about this
public school infrastructure fund which
is a result of the the task force we had
uh that
uh Governor sonunu had put together
together back in
2018 dealing with safety security access
in our schools plus it had some other
components which the infrastructure
could be you fund could be used for uh
for issues that impacted certain
infrastructure within the facilities
that the government Governor saw fit to
use we also had rate which is a uh a
program which was there to supplement
funding for getting um proper
Communications in the schools in the
communities
the eate has gone and since that time
we've spent a little over $50 million to
support the public school infrastructure
fund the the intent of the public school
infrastructure
fund and is to ensure that we are
providing safe secure environments for
our students to learn and live in during
the course of a school
day there is a commission that's put
together I happen to be the chair of
that commission representative Heath is
a member of the commission and the
commission involves folks from Homeland
Security now right now uh Perry plumber
is gone Jennifer Harper's gone but
director abob buckton is on that along
with the commissioner of Education uh
Senators
Representatives uh people from the uh
State Board of
Education and we're all tasked to look
at how we're going to make the these
buildings safer and the environment the
infrastructure in our state that's
relative to education safer for
students the task force report that came
out in
2018 had at least 48 separate
recommendations within it and they all
reference how we can better prepare stud
our teachers students administrators to
react in terms of if there is a
situation that occurs within a building
buildings so it goes even with
recommendations for professional
development to how we're going to build
buildings how we're going to maintain
buildings how we're going to control
access to safety Communications with uh
emergency responders it's a Well Done uh
a document of which we've enacted many
of those recommendations internally
within that
report the commission has met and we
have looked at numerous applic s that
have come in from school districts
there's application process which goes
out and and then uh various communities
schools can apply for these funds up to
$100,000 uh for each project um so we've
gone ahead with that the discussions we
have have been done in closed sessions
because it's a commission what has to do
this in terms of we're dealing with
issues which we don't want everybody out
there in John Q public to know what how
the safety conditions are and how we're
responding those conditions in any
specific
school and the criteria in which we're
looking to evaluate and priority is also
done by Homeland Security with
recommendations coming forward and in
conjunction with the department and
those recommendations come back to the
commission for us to recommend recommend
those projects then it goes on the
fiscal then onto governor and councel
for approval we've already had a bill
that deals with the process there in
terms of trying to shorten that up which
is absolutely necessary we do that this
looks this bill looks at one of the
components within the the statutory uses
for these
monies and one of the issues this bill
was initially put in with the idea of
scratching out item F which was the
energy efficient school buses or other
vehicles used for transportation
students the commission discussed this
at the last Commission meeting we had I
I posed a question about this
bill and one of the representatives
that's on that commission said wait a
minute and she happens to be on this
committee
today suggested well isn't
infrastructure on the bus just as
important we all thought about it for a
second and said yes cameras are
necessary on those buses if there's an
issue on a bus that's part of the
infrastructure of that school
system the bill itself says energy
efficient school buses in terms of the
commission the commission feels all
buses should be you know recognized as
infrastructure whether it's a bus that's
running on electricity or diesel
or hydrogen I don't know um so so what
this bill does and I have an amendment
here for you and I'll pass it out and it
can be passed
around let me just pass this over to
represent
belter the the amendment puts back in
school buses or other vehicles used for
transportation of students it puts a
unlike the bill as
introduced the only two words taken out
are energy efficient this is not I quote
again this is not an e a DE program or a
program which deals with this type of
aspect like we dealt with lead and water
remember we did that several years ago
that was a DS uh uh perspective and
something we we recognize has to be done
the the infrastructure monies right now
are being used for Access Control
Communications safety of students
whether it's energy efficient or
not and so it's the wrong place to
address energy efficient since since the
commission has met we have not used that
as a criteria and we haven't even
discussed it we we are still working on
trying to get our schools safe and we
have spent this year we had $10 million
which we're in the process of of of of
and I think uh Miss Clark will explain
that the applications have been looked
at and it's we're going through those
and
awarding but uh it's it's
uh a criteria of the commission right
now that we look at all the
possibilities of what these can do and
if you look at the statute right now
you'll see what areas within law we
address there's nothing in there I I
truly believe by putting energy
efficient buses in there alone was a
misplace of where we put this in
legislation I'm not speaking to whether
they're good bad or wrong or indifferent
or what I'm just saying right now we
need to address this issue but we need
to address it as all school buses are
part of the infrastructure program this
was looked at by the commission and the
commission was in agreement so I will
conclude my testimony and take any
questions if necessary uh thank you Mr
chairman uh questions uh representative
Woodcock thank you
chair just just as an a slide you in
your I have a problem with your mem bill
it's fine but in terms of energy
efficient school buses do we have any
IDE IDE how many are out there in the
state I don't know you might ask Miss
Clark that
um in this weather this cold weather um
where you get half the mileage and and
uh the costs of those things right now
are horrendous you're talking
4,000 so no I don't know how many are
out there okay um there may be a pilot
program somewhere which is done through
grant money but this is not where we
should be doing it honestly this has to
be a separate yeah than thank you sure
um any further
questions uh seeing none thank you very
much you're welcome chairman next is
Dees welcome thank you um thank you
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Jessica Wilcox and I
supervise the mobile sources section in
the air Resources Division at the
Department of Environmental Services so
basically we look at programs and
projects that support cleaner
Transportation options while we take no
position on this bill we would just like
to point out that energyefficient school
buses particularly electric buses are
good for everybody from the public
health benefits from the low to no
emissions that come to the economic
benefits from fuel maintenance savings
as such we just wanted to make the
committee aware that there are currently
a tons of funds being made available to
New Hampshire school schs through epa's
clean School Bus program this program is
being funded by the bipartisan
infrastructure law and is providing five
billion over five years starting fiscal
year 2022 through 2026 to replace
existing internal combustion engine
school buses with zero emission and as
well as low emission models so if they
are electric school buses if a school
district is interested in that
technology this funding can also support
installation of charging infrastructure
so it's really looking to kind of tuck
in that whole project package so this
PRI this program from EPA is
prioritizing High need school districts
so think those that are in our that are
in our rural areas and they end up
receiving higher funding um what we
looked what we saw in the very first
rebate program that came out in 2022 was
that this program actually provided
almost the entire cost of the electric
School Bus for these priority schools so
as a result of this summer 2022 EPA
rebate program EPA ended up receiving
over 2,000 applications requesting
nearly $4 billion for over 12,000 buses
so there's definitely interested
interest Nationwide in this program here
in New Hampshire rebates were actually
awarded to two priority to New Hampshire
school districts in partnership with
their school transportation provider
Navistar so to answer your question uh
from earlier hener and rumney are
currently have been awarded funding for
I think combined a total of seven
electric school buses and they're
working with their provider to get that
project off the ground and kind of
navigate installing that charging
infrastructure so they're getting
millions of dollars for that a grant
program was also released by EPA in
summer 22 a little bit different from
that earlier rebate program which the
rebate program cash on the hood for any
school districts that want to do it
upfront funding the grant program meant
they might have to kind of field some
funding for a while before they could
actually apply for reimbursement and
that grant program required larger
projects then in Fall of 2023 a PA
opened a second rebate program because
this funding is just in demand and
expects to W at least 500 million in
funding um as I mentioned this funding
does cover almost the entire cost of the
school I just want to make this
committee aware there is tons of funding
out there for energy efficient school
buses and I thank you for your time and
welcome any questions thank you very
much uh representative Heath thank you
Mr chair thank you um that's most
interesting so our local New Hampshire
school districts can apply directly
that's correct they can either apply
directly or with in partnership with
their transportation provider you're
welcome represent beler you Mr chair and
thank you for that testimony about the
EPA program um my question is to do with
electric school buses um we had a
situation happen in New York not New
York City but New York State maybe a
year or two ago uh people got stuck on
the highway in a snowstorm uh dozens of
people died and some of these people had
electric vehicles who could not maintain
heat over an extended period of time
because they don't have that on board we
live in a very cold climate so what is
the circumstance for a Bus full of
children stuck in a stuck in a highway
in a snowstorm under such a circumstance
it's interesting often times the heater
is actually powered by diesel it's kind
of an oxymoron to the whole electric
school bus but the the school bus is
being powered by the battery in the
motor and often times the heating system
is being fueled by diesel fuel so I
can't speak directly to it but you know
the each bus provider offers a different
package but that certainly is an option
to kind of ensure that doesn't happen
further questions representative Hall
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so you said two Romney and
Romney ROM and H hener how many applied
that didn't get it or were they the only
two who applied no there were more that
applied but it was a lottery system in
the very first rebate round um I'm not
sure how many were from New Hampshire
there on the EPA website there is a list
of those that are kind of on a waiting
list um I do believe there was I I am
aware of two other schools that did
apply and did not and were not selected
up in the North Country um but I'm not
sure of sure of the total number um and
additionally in top of the electric
school buses I know that there's a lot
of propane powered school buses
operating in the state and this funding
from EPA also supports schools that are
interested in that technology as well
followup yes could you name those two
schools in the North Country I'm just
curious um I believe it was Berlin I off
the top of my head and Gore him okay
thank you further questions uh yes
representative Cornell thank you and
thank you for taking my question so um
taking energy efficient out of rep lad's
bill doesn't affect energy efficient
buses for schools not it won't affect
this funding not having that in this
bill is not going to affect school's
ability in the state of New Hampshire to
apply for the EPA funding thank
you uh yes representative
Dame thank you so you said the first
round was a lottery is it a lottery
again going forward that's a great
question I don't know off the top of my
head if they're running it the same way
this time I'd have to look into it and I
can certainly share some information
with this committee if if there's
interest thank you very much for being
here thank you so much for your time and
Department
good afternoon for the record my name is
Amy Clark and I'm with the school
facilities Bureau at the Department of
Education and I am just simply here to
if you have any questions about the
public school infrastructure fund uh
representative lad get a a very good uh
description of what the purposes of the
bill but I'm happy to answer any other
questions you
have representative Heath thank you Mr
chair thank you Amy um I'm on the
commission um and it's been quite
interesting one of the things that we
did discuss at our last meeting was the
um are we making sure that we're doing
everything we can to get the schools
that haven't yet applied um and um I
would ask you if you just describe the
steps that have been taken by the
department of Ed and um the um uh office
of Homeland Security toward that end
sure uh in please um sure thank you for
that question in 2018 the fund um was
started that's the Inception of the fund
and at that time there was a total of 28
million that went out in that uh first
batch of um schools and if I recall um
it was a rolling process at that time
and at some point in time the homeland
security reached out to all the school
districts that had not yet applied and
kind of gave them fed them information
to try to encourage them to apply so
that was the first attempt to make sure
that everybody knew about it and then
this last round of funding we've since
that first batch we've had three other
rounds of funding we call them round one
round two round three uh and um round
three funding was based on a first in
first out uh basis however if you had
never received funding from if you are a
school dist not just a school district a
specific school that had not received
funding you dumped that wait list so we
were able to fund all the schools that
had never received funding and we left
that um application deadline open for an
extended period of time to make sure
that schools could get an application
into to fund you're welcome further
questions see none thank you very much
thank you and with that I think uh it
closes um uh House Bill
this
well next bill up on the dock of today
is uh HB
1452 relative to credentials for the
position superintendent schools and
school business officer sir and I
welcome represent luno to introduce the
Bill thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
uh David luno representing the people of
Marmont County District 9 which are the
folks who live in the towns of
hopkington and B but uh but I always say
hey we've got statewide responsibilities
we've heard about these all all um all
day today and and it continues here as
well so um I'm just going to take really
a couple of minutes to uh to introduce
uh House Bill
1452 and uh and pass it along to some uh
some some people that uh that are
Professionals in this area and are going
to going to going to speak to the
importance here and and the the
collaborative work that uh that that uh
will hopefully be coming before us but
um but I want to I want to just take a
couple minutes to sort of lay the
backdrop here um we've all seen it um uh
particularly over the last last few
weeks but even the last year that
there's been a lot of uh storms that
have blown through New Hampshire and um
and some of these storms have um have
obviously affected you know Sea Coast
communities but uh they've also affected
uh the um the Department of Education
and um and uh one of the storms that's
blowing right now is affecting uh the
education rules uh for the minimum uh
stand ards for schools so the 306s we've
heard about those um other storms though
have affected uh uh I think a more I
don't know maybe more Arcane uh area of
rules called the called the 506s if I
have that if I have that right and um
and the 506 rules uh go to the um um the
credentialing standards or the minimum
the standards for for um for school
district administrators and in
particular
superintendents and school business
officers um the um the section of um
with regards to the superintendent rule
rules have really been decimated by uh
by some of these storms and I think
given the responsibilities that
superintendents have and there's only
there's about a 100 superintendant
across the state of New Hampshire that
uh lead School District districts that
that serve the needs of 165,000 students
uh for 180 days uh uh days a year plus
um serving the community needs that uh
that those that those school districts
and school buildings are often used for
um so uh so the superintendent rules in
U in 506 were really decimated the um
the rules for the school business
officers were actually washed out to see
you don't even find can't even find them
anymore and um and and again School
business officers um you know I'm I'm
guessing that that is probably around
the same number of school business
officers that there may be
superintendents because they generally
work in the um in the SAU office but
these 100 School business officers are
responsible for overseeing and managing
budgets that uh that that that top out
um you know over three and A5 billion a
year in taxpayer money and um and to to
think that we wouldn't have standards
for credentialing a school business
officer is really um uh is really you
know quite astounding um given the the
size and the scope of their
responsibilities so what uh what
1452 uh is is here to do um uh as
written is to provide a vehicle for um
uh for the School administrator
Association for New Hampshire asbo the
school business officer uh
Administration to to lay out a statutory
framework for um for rule professional
rules for these very very important
positions that uh that that oversee the
instruction the curriculum the safety of
165,000 students a year and our tax
dollars North of$ three5 billion dollars
uh a year and um and make sure we're
doing um we're doing the right thing not
only for our kids and our families and
our communities but for the taxpayers
that are funding uh these schools you
know I really don't have any any reason
why these storms blew in or
why some of these rules were decimated
and others were were washed out to shore
um the rules may have simply expired uh
but regardless I think it's important
that the state of New Hampshire has have
U have have competent rules in place
that uh that really you know provide
some backbone to these very very
important positions so with that I'm
happy to take some questions but I know
there's some folks here that I think can
lay some more technical detail behind
this thank you very much are questions
for represent luno yes thank you Mr
chair um for years we've had standards
for our superintendents our principles
our business coordinators our um and
they're usually based on National
guidelines that have been posted by the
chief State School Officers
Association how could that possibly have
changed so thank you for for the
question representative Heath um I'm
sorry I I I honestly don't know how uh
how it changed uh I know some of these
changes I think were made uh were made
very quickly by our state board um and
um uh and and
and but but I think rather than looking
at it as a as a um as a problem which it
is a problem um if we can look at it as
an opportunity to to uh take a look at
um at the rules that were in place what
sort of updates could be made to those
rules based on best practices based on
what uh what we're seeing in other areas
across the country and based on what our
needs are in New Hampshire uh I think
we've got a good opportunity here and um
and again you know I'm not the expert in
this area I know there are some on this
this committee who are experts um in
this but uh but we do have a lot of
expertise throughout the state as well
that I think can help us um uh put uh
put strong robust um uh rules um uh for
our you know kids families communities
and
taxpayers represent
beler thank Mr chair and thank you rep
luno we have um I have I'm looking at a
specific line and I need a little bit of
clarification so down on item F number
one describing the um necessary
qualifications for a superintendent are
you looking in the bill I'm just yes
okay the
page oh I'm I'm looking at the whole
yeah um f F1 it starts exerting
professional
influence it's page four L to page four
at the top thank you for that um so
under the qualifications for
superintendent it says exerting
professional influence improving the
broader political social economic legal
and cultural context of education for
all students and families through active
participation in the local community and
the larger education policy environment
can you give me an example example of
what what is intended by especially the
political education of
students I'm still trying to find it I'm
I'm seeing it on page three at the
bottom page four line three page four
line oh oh all right so the f starts
um so again I there there's no intent by
the the the language that's here uh it
was taken from from some national uh
positions so I I I'm I'm really really
Lo using this bill as a placeholder for
collaborative work with the with the
professional associations uh in the
question yes represent
cascaden thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'm not sure if
this applies to what your presentation
is or to um someone else is going to
testify but are you telling me that
there was
such a sore change or a storm as you
described that the current 302 uh rule
is not being
followed the 302 which is a duties of
school superintendent identify Ed rules
I I I don't know about that I'm I'm
talking about the 506 rules for
superintendant I think three the the 302
right um and and I did take a look that
that lists a very very long list of
responsibilities uh that superintendent
have in the management and oversight of
our school districts I I I I think the
original rules would reflect upon that
to make sure that the that people who
were were applying to be superintendant
had the qualifications to be able to
exercise that degree of management and
and oversight but that the the rules
with respect to their qualifications
have changed as such so that it's
now not
um not clear as to as to whether whether
somebody applying to be a superintendent
would actually have the um the skills
and experience uh and background
qualifications to be able to provide uh
to be able to um exercise their duties
as laid out follow up so are you talking
about credentialing I am that that's the
506 rules I haven't heard that term I
believe so
thanks yes Ron
cordelli thank you um right now in
statute um Ru making Authority um for
the board includes qualification duties
for superintendents principles school
administrative unit personnel and other
Public School
Employees
um have
there been
identified uh problems with people in
the field due to maybe a change in the
requirements um in the 506s is that why
this is coming forward now so thank you
very uh very much for the question
representative cordelli um I I the the
as as I understand it the changes were
made uh fairly recently certainly within
the last year and um and specifically I
recall being at the state board meeting
where the uh where where the elimination
of the school business officer rules
were uh were changed I believe
proceeding that um there were there were
significant changes made to the the
rules for
superintendent and um and so I'm I'm not
aware of of what sort of um impact those
rule changes have had on the 100 or so
superintendent and 100 or so School
business officers uh
that that are currently employed uh
across our state but but should this go
on much longer and and uh we heard
earlier today that um that turnover
among
superintendant um can be fairly high
that we may start to see some effects
from lowering these standards um for for
credentialing in these senior leadership
positions yes
um would the same apply for principles
because that's also listed as one of the
responsibility there there's there there
are um um there there is a standard in
place for principles there's I think a
standard in place for um for uh you know
um um different administrators uh in
there I'm not aware to what extent those
rules may have changed uh others to
speak after may have um additional
information but this bill really focuses
specifically on
on you know two of the and I don't want
to say most important everybody's got a
role in a in a public school district um
you know if you're if you're if you're a
parent you're a student you know your
teachers are important your principes
are important um when you when you show
up at a school district meeting and vote
on budget budgets your school board is
there the superintendent is there the
business officer is there when you're at
a budget committee meeting I think we
had a a bill the other day about
Municipal budget committees the business
officer is there and and for um you know
for 12 years presenting School budgets
and going through and basically um you
know shepherding our budget process
through our Municipal budget committee
that
trust that members of the community who
serve whether they're serving on a
school board or serving on a municipal
budget committee have with the school
business officer is incredible it is so
important and um and they have to be
able to believe what they're hearing
particularly in a very very complicated
um School budgets aren't easy they're
not easy and um and and and to leave to
leave the professional qualifications up
in the air to be all right um we're
we're not we're not going to set a hard
deck as to what your qualifications need
to be what your experience and
background needs to be
then then you know I I would be
concerned that we're um we're setting
ourselves up for um for challenges down
the road and now is the opportunity
where we can address
it are there further questions for
represent represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so I see a big disconnect
between the two or three lines in here
that say you need to make rules about
the qualifications for these offices and
the minutia that's five pages long
here this looks to me more like rules
than um than than um enabling you know
is there some kind of medium that you
can can make uh rather than putting this
in the statute ABS absolutely thank you
very much for the for the question uh
representative dry um I I would I would
absolutely suggest that that we we we go
to a to what what I would call more of a
stat statutory framework for the rules
making sure that the that the statute
contains all of the required elements
that would we would be looking for in
rule making and then leave it to the
department to um to you know flesh out
the um and the department and the board
and the and and jel car to um uh to
flush out the uh the rest of those rules
but uh where we've seen rules either
decimated or or completely obliterated
that um that that maybe we need to have
something more in statute than was there
than is either there now or was there
before uh to provide the department with
better guidance as to what we intend as
a legislature to uh to to you know want
to see to to you know the most um you
know senior leaders in our um in our
school
districts uh I have a question for are
you aware that there is an exemption I
see exception to this for small school
districts where a principal can take on
this leadership responsibility as an
administrator yeah I I am aware of that
uh 194 C3 yeah and and I'm I'm I'm aware
of it I'm not aware of all of the
functional elements of that I don't know
if it's open-ended can go on forever um
I I think there was even a um what's the
term is it alt or something alter
alternative yeah yeah but but something
for superintendant that didn't meet all
the qualifications but were working
towards those qualifications that they
could serve as superintendent and and
I'm not trying to trying to you know say
that we can't do that because I think
there there there's there's clearly
value in making sure that um that that
um that a school board can hire a
superintendent or School business
officer that they feel can can meet
their needs but subject to to at at
least a a um uh set of qualifications
and criteria for credentialing that uh
that protects the um the interest the
safety uh of the students of the the
visitors of the parents of the
communities that use those buildings
facilities we talk about facilities a
lot very important thing superintendant
have those responsibilities School
business officers have those
responsibilities too and that um and
that that we make sure that um that our
our senior leaders have the um have the
qualifications and capability to um U to
exercise their responsibility so we what
I'm trying to drive home is that do we
need to do this through statute or is it
best done through 506 because I'm
looking at the statute and I explored
this too I have a master's program and
and uh this says the superintendent of a
single School District may qualify
alternative certification as principal
instruction leader who has undergone a
rigorous process that ensures that
individual has gained necessary
competency skills and knowledge required
for certification in an ad
administrative role as determined by the
Department of Education so the
department working with the board then
is the responsible agent agency to to
Define this broad language which we've
given and the Masters plus 5 years
experience is what they're talking about
yeah except thank you for the uh for the
clarification on that except that's not
what the State Board of Education told
me when U uh when I was there and
testifying on the U on the the the wipe
out of the school business officer um
qualifications they said if you want to
see qualifications in rules then you
better enact some law that's what I was
told okay thank
you ref
Santana thank you so just as a followup
to that so is your proposal to make the
clear intent of a statute to
underly what the rules then are drawn up
on if that's thank you very much
representative Tanner for the question I
believe all rules have to be able to
lean on on statute um at least I think
that's what we've been told that there
needs to be a statutory underpinning for
for administrative rules um uh I it it
it doesn't appear that that what what
may be in statute now was sufficient to
um to to was a sufficient underpinning
maybe for the um the rules that have
been wiped out um and uh and the intent
here is is to provide that statutory
underpinning I hope that that that it's
not up to the legislature to to get down
you know into the the really the
detailed professional levels um of here
but of of of what would be required
because I think that's beyond our I I
think that's beyond what what we're
expected to do and I don't think this NE
necessarily needs to be you know a
20page bill but I think it needs to be
sufficiently clear so that the state
board and the commissioner can uh can
develop rules and um and and revise
those rules as necessary to stay within
the um the the
statutory U uh framework that uh that we
would provide and you're putting this
legislation together the proposed the
bill did you ask the question that every
10 years rules have to be looked
at and by that agency and brought before
Jael car have you asked the question why
we meaning Jael car then have not
modified the 506 or
if you're saying that some of this is
not there anymore it's been deleted why
was it deleted by and Allowed by Jael
car us why we do that yeah yeah that's a
that's a great question when when I was
at the State Board I was told if you
want any of this to remain then you you
should put it in law and so I take that
meaning to mean that we didn't have
enough statutory framework in place in
order to hold on to uh to the rules that
they were they were significant L
reducing or um or you know eliminating
completely so so I I wish I had a better
answer for you and others um um the um
School administrator Association I
believe is is signed up to to speak and
um and they may have more clarity on
that thank you further
questions thank you very much oh you
have one hand up I didn't see it yes
thank you Mr chair I just I just had one
followup because you were talking about
the need to provide further Frameworks
to the Department of Education to guide
them a little more firmly I'm going to
say something surprising I'm in total
agreement with
that however I some of the specifics
make me a little more Curious so
actually I brought up one line I want to
look at the next one which is
F2 where again we're talking about the
specific requirements for a um
superintendent to be contributing to the
educational policy and political uh
policy environment and political support
for excellence and equity in education
striving to uphold an influence
influence federal state and local laws
policies and regulations statut and
statutory requirements and effectively
communicating with key decision makers
in the community and in broader
political context to support student
learning that sounds like there is an
explicitly political component to this
job description
that seems to be something more akin to
what you would expect an elected
official to undertake can you speak to
that sure um I again th this is example
framework in here and not and not what
um uh but that being said what you just
read I think is an example of what we
see um every day when we're uh when
we're in here with hearings there are um
uh administrators from various districts
will come in and testify there will be
administrators from from uh different
executive part departments outside of
school districts that will come in and
testify and those are political they are
performing political work there not
partisan work it's not partisan it's
political though uh we're clearly a
political body here and we rely on
expertise from uh from people who who
are in the field and um and and and
understand these areas you know I dare
say maybe better than we do and um and
being able to to take that testimony uh
is uh is important and I think that's
all that that paragraph is um is gaming
to further questions thank you very much
great thank you Mr
chair next person is Dean
[Music]
cascaden
than
hey it's great to be
back lot you know me see a lot of
familiar friends around the room um and
I'm just going to talk to you today
about Ed leadership but I'm going to
touch on a lot of things that you're
going to face this year first of all
thank you representive luno for putting
this forward I may be able to answer
some of the questions that have come out
if you give me leave to do that and one
clarifying thing before we start I am
not married to that woman over there she
uh she is uh my sister-in-law
uh my former my brother Neil who passed
away I bet you were wishing you were
married to her I wish I was married no
my wife is never we'll get
there so so I almost wore my t-shirt
today which says I love New Hampshire
public education and we got those as
superintendents um just to talk about
and I've been in it for a long time I
started um over with representative dry
over in Hanover I was principal of a
little Christian school and um I I knew
that I knew private school went away and
got a doctorate came back to the state
and went into public school and I'm an
un batched supporter of public school I
just am I just it it has happened I
understand the politics but um so I
didn't wear the T-shirt CU I also got a
haircut believe it or not I got a
haircut just before com in here so yeah
pretty long uh because I I I do respect
this this group and I I do thank you
it's been a long time here represent lad
I thank you for your leadership it'll be
a couple things I'm going to touch on
for you but let me just start with this
money is essential we won't talk about
that today but it's common the lawsuits
comell lawsuit Rand lawsuit it's coming
money is essential I mean started up in
sau36 and then I came down to B because
what could I do in the school system if
the first question wasn't how do we pay
for it if the first question was what
should we do but money is essential
we'll talk about that second later on
leadership is absolutely essential and
there are vared situations in New
Hampshire I mean I started an sau36
Cooperative School District Seven towns
all to coming together into one board I
went down to Bose single district and
then we lured Dunbarton in so I became a
multi-district sa over there and now I
am semi-retired I'm in
Grandam which is on the Western frontier
of the state I'm two days a week
part-time
interim and those are all very different
situations for educational leadership
and we're trying to write a rule we're
trying to write a bill that covers all
of those and it's very difficult so
that's the first thing you got to
remember these situations are all
different the second thing you got to
remember is we're a state of local
control and school
boards um I remember when Frank first
came on he was I'm sorry commissioner El
first came on he was talking to me about
you know well how can I get the
superintendant to do what I want and I
said you can't
it it's just not it used to be that the
commissioner of Education signed the
paycheck and evaluated and now I'm
evaluated by my local school board I'm
basically paid by my local school board
and with all due respect Barrett uh
School boards are amateur
organizations there there's no
requirement to be a Schoolboard member
except for you're a voter in town you
get elected and a lot of good people get
elected to boards and they have great
ideas but they're amateurs in the sense
that they don't understand the
professional environment they don't
understand everything that has to happen
superintendent Bas are professionals
absolutely there's a requirement in both
superintendent and ba certification that
you get a college
degree I'm not sure how useful that is
in my actual day-to-day job but it does
give me exposure to Theory it does give
me exposure to larger ideas of Education
um and so forth but the real day-to-day
job I can only learn from other
superintendents and business
administrators especially in New
Hampshire because it is so unique so you
got nhsaa and you got asbo Mark's here
he's from nhsa we don't have an ASO
representative
but Dr mlan sorry um and they're the
ones who provide most for professional
development they're the ones who help us
interpret they're the ones who help us
build the field and the very practical
application more so with school business
administrators you have asbo and they
work together these organizations they
meet they talk they deal with the laws
that come up from you we deal with the
stuff that comes down from the State
Board of Education and we talk about how
can we best implement this and how can
we go forward so education
Administration it is about Theory and
it's about very practical application um
so it's a craft you know it's a little
bit of Art and Science and so forth but
we are professionals and we are
sometimes the only Professionals in the
District who are paying attention to
these things now one of the things you
need in order to have successful um
school is long-term stable
Administration and you have a turnover
problem in your school leaders it's a
hard job it's a tough job you know the
joke is it's a three-year cycle first
year you get to know them the second
year you try to implement some stuff and
the third year you're updating your
resume and you're out looking for a new
Jump but there's a churn and and and
that doesn't do our Public Schools any
good
okay the first thing in the first item
in the
um rules see this should be in rules it
really should be you're right you
shouldn't be dealing with this at the
legislative body this should be in your
Department of Education rules and the
things that were stripped the the tie
that he's talking about happened in
those 10 years revision and one of the
thing um the first thing that that
starts is
Vision an education leader has
to build a vision and Muriel reminded me
of this a couple sorry representative
Hall reminded me of this she said when
you first interviewed a Bo you came down
and said it's not my vision it's our
vision and that p a public educational
leader has to go in the community and
respect all in the community and bring
that Community together and create a
vision create a plan create a rallying
point so that the community can come
together
and and rally around their schools pay
for their schools support their schools
and do that that that's number one and
that's so difficult because we have
divided communities we just went through
an election you know that that it just
split look at your body you're split 550
and it's partisan there's divided
communities and it is hard to go in a
community and bring everyone into the
table everyone gets a seat that seat on
the kindergarten rug and say okay we're
going to come together and we're going
to do in a very respectful way we're
going to talk talk to each other we're
going to solve problems we're going to
decide what our vision is for our Public
School in this community and each one's
different what I'm doing in Grand them
was different what I do in 36 what I did
in v and and it's hard so what you do is
you focus on student a achievement for
all Al for everybody and what tried to
get stripped out of the uh
superintendent and I don't know if it's
back in but when we were talking about
re redoing the superintendent rules the
500 you're talking about was the concept
of
equity number one an educational leader
has to be committed to equity why
because we educate all in the public
school and so you have to be committed
to having all come in and making sure
you are meeting the needs of all that's
equity and that was being stripped from
the rules and now in the in the bill
that I read that's number one build a
vision that has equity and that you're
educating all and you're educating to
them to high
standards um and you know when I in B
the proudest thing it was a mission
statement the first thing was care for
each person every day focus on the
individual and just care for them what
what do they need they need eat lunch we
get lunch you need some clothing we give
clothing you need some emotional needs
met because you can't learn yeah we're
going to work on that too and we're also
going to have to teach you teach you to
read write Cipher and all those other
things because we focus on learning
that's the major thing that we should do
but we do it by looking at individuals
and because we are committed to equity
what is it that each student needs to be
the best person they can be and
contribute to our
society so in there you've got a bunch
of areas so let me talk about those
areas what a superintendent is totally
responsible for and usually who does
them finances operations human resource
Transportation facilities Food Service
risk management that's usually your ba
that's the financial side of the house
you
know how we going to pay for things how
do we pay for things operations how do
we run things how do you keep the
building clean how do you do all your
human relation stuff and hire and fire
and and pay people how do you get kids
back and forth to school keep a you know
Food Service oh my goodness all the
federal regulations on that then you
have another big area called C and PD
curriculum assessment instruction
professional development curriculum the
standards we're going to look at
assessments how we look at kids and make
sure that they're learning and
instruction how we actually instruct
them and then how do we teach teach
teachers usually you have a c person in
your SAU you have a person that's going
to focus on that area I
know I'm G you were a Cai person because
I tried to get your job one year or when
you left I tried to get your job and and
you you were excellent at it and I
started in that realm but that wasn't me
and it's data assessment data informed
ass ISS all right special education the
next one usually there's a central
office person in special education
highly technical very um uh easy to get
in trouble a lot of rules you're dealing
with the most fragile and the most needy
kids in your district and it is totally
organized here's what I almost forget to
put down um repone Hollywood is very
angry at me Labor Relations and
unions Miro was my uh my uh
uh Union head when I was in BO it's
you're in a union environment you got to
negotiate a CBA you got to live by a CBA
and although she may not believe it I am
pro-union in education I think they
represent the teachers they represent
the teachers interests and they need to
be represented because they're the ones
who actually deliver education to our to
our
students then just the stuff that
everyone does safety security physical
cyber and emotional
yeah we got to build schools almost like
prisons now with with with with
entrances that prevent lockdowns we got
to teach kids what to do if an intruder
comes walking through your door with
with a
rifle that's tough emotional security we
deal with kids who are have adverse
childhood um events and they need to
come in and make sure that they are safe
and secure for they can learn and then
cyber security I don't know if you heard
what happened to Newfound but they lost
all their data they got hacked they got
hacked they lost everything everything
they don't even have their special ed
records so you better have some cyber
security in there because you're going
to be um difficult then you do some team
building evaluation with people you do
community engagement you do board work
and policy and then to your question you
do the larger political context I I go
to the State Board of Education I come
here to see you and talk to you to to
hopefully help you do your
job so Bas they're also educational
leaders and there's no certification now
so last year the ba went uh Dwayne Ford
is my ba I went and talked to him this
morning I don't want to misrepresent him
I'm here just talking about me I'm not
talking about nhsa or anything but the
certification no longer
exists uh the the the problem is there
is no College Prep program for Bas right
now there just isn't so you go and you
get a a preparation in finance or or
some sort of college degree but asbo
actually had developed a very good ba
certification program that uh that they
were running and they were getting up
off the ground and they went to the
state board and they said hey you know
we know it's difficult to to have Bas we
know it's difficult to find a
preparation program but here's asbo and
they were just told we're not going to
have that certification anymore no
reason no rule just we're not going to
have the certification anymore um and
that's too bad and and Dwayne would like
to see it come back I've talked to my BA
down in Grandam she'd like to see him
come back because some sense they are
the real leaders of the district because
I often had to ask Dwayne permission to
spend money because money rules and
they're Reales and it's highly regulated
technical job so can we can we get
certification back for Bas and I don't
think you have to argue about what that
has to look like in here but I agree
that you really should should have one
um and there's a shortage of Ed leaders
you know why well we're on the front
line of the cultural War we know that we
lead divided Comm unities and right now
there's a there's a culture of
Confrontation and sound bites it's very
hard to pull the opposite sides together
and get collaboration and problem
solving I think later on you'll deal
with another problem there are too many
districts districts are splitting apart
from each other there just so many
superintendent open and a lot of them
are small so you'll be looking at
consolidation any uh soon and there are
too many boards I mean I talk to
superintendents who have 13 boards or
not 13 boards but 13 nights out because
they have all these boards they have to
report to boards take time to manage and
so
forth and I just want to say that that
these educational jobs are a full-time
247365 job
247365 I have to have this phone on all
the time and be able to be contacted
because you never know when something's
going to happen like this morning I
didn't think it was a bad snowstorm but
they called me up and said hey I had a
terrible time getting into school today
how come we didn't call off school like
and even part-time you have this all
these things that I described to you in
a big system you got all sorts of
different people doing them in a small
system that's all one person so let me
finish up here I'm sorry I've taken so
long you know but I still I still have a
lot of a lot of hope I do because you
know I I believe in educational
leadership I believe in public schools
we teaching to touch the future it's
about the kids in our future if we can
build a society where all are valued all
are encouraged to contribute if we can
build a society or we can debate policy
without attacking or denigrating the
other then I think we can build a
society that learns and grows and can
deal with complex issues like climate
change like AI like distribution of food
and
energy so in
some I speak in support of this
bill um I think we need to support
public educ
a um I'm going to talk a little bit
about the state board and
commissioner uh it's difficult right now
because their focus is on efas Charters
and and and using money for private
education understand that political
world I'm I'm not here to debate it but
you go back into their agendas you go
back into the things that they're paying
attention to those are the things are
paying attention can can you stick to
the bill please you got it so you got
the 306s the essential regulations that
um the minimum
standards that's a huge one that needs
to support Public Schools it's been kind
of
outsourced you know I this is what I
wanted to talk to to you representative
lad about I know you get upset about the
failure to file reports I mean you need
good data you need data as a legislator
the state needs data and it's getting
better you know with the State student
information system and navigating the
DOA single sign on and I wanted to give
a shout out to Caitlyn and this
gentleman right here who was my I was
his middle school principal um Mark you
know they do a really good job
supporting us in public education
Caitlyn runs uh a once a month call
which talks about all that technical
stuff I talked about she covers it and
she covers who does it so sorry for the
long-winded one I don't get out of the
house much these days I'm sem re tired
but I just wanted to give you a flavor
for what educ ational leaders alike and
yes we do need standards for Ed leaders
both superintendents and principles uh
superintendents and Bas but it really
should be done at the state board but
it's not thank you thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um you noted that
schools are in fact in a tough spot
right now there schools are really
schools are at the Forefront as you said
of the culture war and uh there's a lot
of divisive things out there happening
um I can certainly understand that
environment um you said that you have to
bring all these communities together and
you also said that schools really in
order to serve the students must as a
foremost operating principle align
around the concept of equity but we've
seen in in many places in other states
from presidential candidates that um
Equity is being prohibited from the
classrooms it's happening in Florida
it's happening in Texas it's happening
in Oklahoma uh multiple presidential
cand candidates have talked about that
the Supreme Court struck down equity and
admissions at Harvard based on
discrimination so I I guess my question
is how How are schools able to bring
these divided communities together if
they're orienting themselves around what
is ultimately a divisive political
Equity I get schooled on Equity by Cy
like it and I was I was very similar I
like what's this Equity thing what why
do we need it
equality is we when we give everyone the
same
thing Equity is when we look at the
individual need of the person and we may
give more to a person than another
person for example a special needs
student I have a special need student
who we are paying probably I think
around $400,000 to educate that single
student that's Equity that student needs
that and able to function and and that's
the principle of equity I'm talking
about the principle of equity is looking
at the individual needs of the community
and giving what is needed at the time
now there's also deij I won't I won't
get into there there are historical
groups that are that are under
repesentative and have been underserved
I mean you can look at statistics about
minority students and what what why do
black boys tend not to read it's not
that they can't read it's not that
they're any less talented it's that they
haven't had the resources put to them so
there are some historic groups but I
would agree with you we can't go too far
the other way in trying to balance out
historic injustices and create inequity
in what we're doing now but the basic
concept is everyone comes in and gets
what they need in our school but thank
you further questions from the
committee thank you very much have a
mlan
you
one good afternoon Mr chairman committee
thank you for a few moments my name is
Mark mlan I'm the executive director of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association and I chose a tough act to
follow um I promise I will be brief ER
than my esteemed colleague and I I won't
have any nautical es like representative
luno it won't be a fireside chat like
you just experienced with Dr cascaden
and uh representative lad I tried to
write neat on my card uh because i' I've
heard you reference that in the past so
I I really did try to write I didn't
write incursive I tried to write neat
though good um so uh I I represent the
New Hampshire school administrators
Association which are system leaders
from around the state of New Hampshire
which is inclusive of superintendant
assistant assistant superintendant
curriculum leaders and business
officials we collaborate with the school
boards Association we collaborate with
the principal's Association we
collaborate with the um with nasbo as
well the business officials Association
and essentially we want to ensure that
we are all working together to the
benefit of the public education system
and the 165,000 or so students that are
in the care of uh all the Great Schools
across our state so um I have spoken uh
briefly with representative luno about
this bill and as representative luno
stated essentially this is a placeholder
Bill to ensure that we have a way to
bring forward standards that hold high
standards for New Hampshire's B business
and superintendent officials but also
provide some
flexibility excuse me as Dr cascaden
referenced each school is different each
school system is different and needs are
different in the North Country you have
schools and districts that are having
trouble recruiting educational leaders
um I think that seven of the 10
superintendents in the North country are
going to there's going to be some
turnover there within the next year or
so that's a significant turnover and for
for the state and for public education
schools to be able to attract quality
Leaders with standards and to ensure
that they have the skills and support
that they need to succeed we do need
some standards in place but we also need
some flexibility in place and I believe
that we can work with representative
luno to craft a bill uh and some
language that provides that so I'm
certainly uh willing to answer any
questions that you may have but um just
wanted to let folks know that we support
high standards we also support
flexibility and we want to ensure that
we have the ability to attract and
retain talented educational leaders and
just for context I was a superintendent
for nine years so I did beat the
three-year average and I was an
assistant superintendent for 3 years
before that so I did 12 years of service
in um the SAU level and honestly I
enjoyed every minute of it thank you
representa cascaden thank you Mr chair
thank you for my um for taking my
question I don't know if you have this
answer but I haven't been a
superintendent in two years since I left
line what drastically
changed in the rules um for
superintendents can you yeah anything
out particular so if you look at the
rules that are in this particular bill I
believe a lot of that is a roll back to
the previous rules that were existed
along with some other placeholder
language that representative Luna uh
grabbed um the my understanding of the
changes to the 506 is it was 50601 which
is the standards for superintendent and
I don't know off the top of my head what
the actual reference is for um business
officials but it's in the 506 I believe
pulled it up um also it's connected to
50503 and uh 5054 I believe which is
about um the way that you can get
certified um I I believe that
superintendents need us the option of a
site-based licensing plan because we
need to be able to work with leaders uh
in a way that allows folks to understand
the New Hampshire way of doing it
connect with experienced colleagues and
uh the current changes actually has the
language that allows for a mentor
program a state board approved Mentor
program and the New Hampshire school
administrators Association is currently
working on a state board approved Mentor
program which they had been working on
prior to any of these changes these
changes and potentially the ability to
put site-based licensing plans back into
certification standards allows for folks
to learn from colleagues in the field to
learn the New Hampshire way and
additionally it allows for some clearer
reciprocity because we do have some
issues with reciprocity right now where
we have superintendents and educational
leaders from other states who come in
and have issues gaining certification
I've had many conversations with Folks
at the department and they're extremely
supportive and collaborative when it
comes to working on the rulemaking as
well so I do believe that there is a
good effort on all fronts right now to
ensure that we have high standards there
should be credentialing standards for
all all of these important positions but
at the same time to recognize that if
we're not reacting to supply and demand
in a way that we're changing some of the
way that we're looking at this then
we're just going to continue to
exacerbate the problems that we have
when it comes to Personnel
shortages
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here um Dr cascaden mentioned
earlier the importance of tenure within
the uh superintendency as far as
visioning and leading the district Etc
uh do you know or you aware of what what
is in fact the average tenure of a
superintendent in a particular School
District before they move to another one
right now the national average last time
I did the research was 2.8 years and um
that actually was the same average in
1920 as it was in
2020 um and I think that's indicative of
the fact that it's an incredibly complex
job and based on the size and the scope
of the system and honestly the the skill
set of the person in charge they're
going to be connected to all of those
disperate systems that you heard Dr
cascaden allude to so in New Hampshire
um I have not done the research but I
believe it's relatively close to that
same three-year national average but
Across the Nation the last I knew the a
rose somewhere around 2.8 Years thank
you yeah further questions representa
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my questions didn't the rule
change um on credentialing for
superintendant really interrupt programs
that were go ongoing at that time are
you referring uh thank you for the
question are you referring to higher
education programs uh the super yes the
higher education programs to uh
credential superintendant or to train
superintendant um I the New Hampshire
school administrators Association has an
articulation and agreement with Southern
New Hampshire University and recently
uh the CTE the um the council for
Teacher education I think that uh stands
for um not CTE as in what used to be
formerly vocational education um
connected with um Southern New Hampshire
University as they are getting their
program approved and they met with
glowing reviews as to what they've done
thus far and um that will be in front of
the stateboard I believe at their
February meeting but um I can't speak at
with any sort of level of of uh command
relative to how much it impacted ongoing
programs I can tell you that some
programs such as uh Plymouth and some
other programs had closed some of their
um administrative credentialing programs
prior to that rule change and some of it
is just kind of based on um what's
happening at those schools but I do
believe if there is some appropriate
flexibility again that maintains high
standards we may be able toing breathe
some life back into those
programs have you worked with uh Steve
applebe over at the department in terms
of um if you're a school board and your
superly we have have a lot of those
positions are open right now is there
reciprocity between the New England
states in terms of superintendent ship
uh where if I get my Cas at Oro is that
then accepted here in New Hampshire um
thank you for the question I you know I
I don't know that reciprocity at this
point is a crystal clear process I
believe there are some ways uh to ensure
that's happening but I think there are
Hoops that must have to be um
encountered so um I have spoken to Steve
applebe quite a bit um I have him on
speed dial he and I have connected quite
often I connected with Bill Ross as well
and Laura ston King and Laura ston King
is connected to uh the programs that get
approved um for for um preparation
programs at at higher ed so in regard to
reciprocity I there have been some
issues because we've had superintendents
from other states Massachusetts Maine uh
surrounding states who have had issues
gaining their certification so right now
although reciprocity I think exists in
some aspects of the law it's not clear
and I believe there are um language
issues that make it difficult for people
who have done the job in other states my
last question for you and then I when
when a superintendent decides to leave
the district i. we just lost one up in
Newfound Lake Area um does does your
organization the school administrators
Association do anything like an exit
interview or discussion try to start
ranking down the rationale and the
reasons or why the why folks are leaving
is it just you know the 13 different
meetings you have to conduct at with
school boards throughout the world here
or is it because of Aging out or is it
because of medical reasons what
what we're very connected to the
superintendent and system leaders when I
say we the New Hampshire school
administrators Association to
superintendent and system leaders around
the state so when there are changes that
are happening we're typically very
connected to the reasons why that is
happening so for example um you
reference Newfound Lake uh we've been in
contact with um superintendent nyas um
we've had conversations with folks that
have been connect that have been
interested and applying for that job so
we'll continue to support those
superintendents as they move out of
their current role and look for and or
move into new roles and essentially um
we also work very significantly with
superintendents who are new to the state
or new to the position through a variety
of ways through the granite state
Leadership Academy we have new system
leader orientation every single year and
we uh connect with folks in a lot of the
informal ways as well but do we have a
formal um exit interview process we
don't have a formal exit interview
process but we do have a lot of
connections and understand the reasons
why folks are leaving sometimes those
are confidential reasons uh sometimes
those are very very public reasons thank
you
questions thank you very much thank
you and we do not have any other cards
on this bill so we will exit this
bill okay can you grab mark yeah I'll
get her to go
go now by the way for the committee the
bills which we did not execute this
morning they have been put on the next
week's docket so we won't be dealing
with any more today on those
me no we're just picking up where that
motion was so that those sessions will
continue at the next round of executive
sessions which we have that'll be first
one on the doc we got to get these early
bills completed going on right now we
have
yeah that that's correct we're in that
week yeah and that that should be out
what Teddy's
Wednesday tomorrow yeah Y and there's a
slug of slug of bills on that we have
me I on see Monday I don't think so I
don't think see yeah there are bills on
Monday I'm trying to think if are the
hearings is we have two hearings in I
sessions yeah
yeah session that's right you're going
to have at least three days in this room
done sort
of well if you're on a subcommittee or
something else like I'm over doe on
Friday yeah okay next bill is HB
1265 this bill is relative to the
penalty for failure to file School
expenditure reports um I think maybe
there's one before that yeah oh that
excuse me I'm the wrong line here there
are two superintendent bills here
relative to the duties and
responsibilities of superintendents of
1552 go for it represent cordelli uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable colleagues for the record
Glenn cordelli representing tuon Boro
Molton B tuon Boro wolfboro and oopy in
the beautiful Lakes Region and uh this
hopefully is a a little simpler bill um
the handout that I gave you is just in
case you don't have your books with you
is uh sections 194 C4 and C5 which we
will be talking about
primarily uh the main objective of this
bill is if you look at 194 C5
2A superintendent services are
required superintendence or
not um very often reading through the um
education rsas and and elsewhere you'll
see that it just says the superintendent
shall do this or do that there's 20 25
spots where that occurs
um I thought that we should make it
accurate
throughout U by saying the
superintendent or Personnel assigned to
perform superintendent Services as per
194 C5
2A um so in this
bill
under 194c which you'll see on the flip
side of the page um outlines the
superintendent services
and there are quite a few of them um
through
R uh we insert a section and this is in
lines 3 through
five
um basically that um this title the
superintendent uh May
mean uh Personnel assigned to perform
these Services which hopefully should
cover most of the
doe um
rsas that we all know and love um on
lines through through um 12 or so U
there is this fire safety uh section of
law that also refers to superintendence
so we modify that uh RSA
15314 to add or Personnel assigned to
perform superintendent services
um
likewise there is a section in 170 which
um is um a conglomeration of many
different uh Ru making
authorities um related to
confidentiality and one of them uh
B3 uh dealt with superintendence so
there again we added that same language
or Personnel assigned to perform those
services and then the last section for
single administrative units um this was
uh a need uh brought to our attention
with this bill that is superintendent in
a single District could also get
alternative certification we talked
representative lad just talked about
alternative certification a few minutes
ago uh this would be U for allowing uh
especially in a small small SAU uh you
know I know of three 400 student saus
and the superintendent could qualify uh
as a principal as well as superintendent
so that's that's the intent to that
section and that really covers uh the
intent of the Bill thank you thank you
any questions for representa cordelli
representative Heath thank you um from
my days gone by when I served in some of
those rules um the
superintendent usually well I worked in
moderate size and bigger school
districts usually the superintendent had
assigned someone else to do that task um
because there are there are a list of
things that the superintendents are
responsible for submitting and making
sure are in place in the school
districts um usually somebody else did
it um being assistant I did a lot of
that stuff but the superintendent always
signed off on it so my fear by
designating another other person um that
who may or may not um do their job if if
the superintendent doesn't ultimately
have to be responsible for it that task
may end up NE never getting done or
there might be some oversight and
ultimately the superintendent is the
final word um along with the school
board of course but the superintendent
holds that responsibility for all of
those tasks so that's my only concern um
because usually that happens anyway but
somebody has to be responsible for
getting those reports to the doe and
making sure they're signed off on it's
like the insurances that we have to sign
every year um saying that we adhere to
these things um it it's somebody's got
to be the boss so that's my only concern
about designating somebody else could
you respond please sure thank you um
yeah I
think
sorry thank you um uh indicating is that
some of these um services on the other
side of the page uh certainly could be
developed or performed by someone else a
design if you will assistant um and I
don't see any problem with that but the
statute does say that it the school
districts especially small districts are
not required to have a
superintendent they could assign someone
to the to perform those services and in
that case that Personnel that staff
person would be
responsible um for performing those
services and be the one whose uh name
was on the bottom line and that they
were being performed or the reports
submitted to doe as you indicate
thank further questions yes
representative Woodcock and then
representative Damon thank
you thank you um a couple questions uh
specifically uh
towards the line of us um I'm looking at
the two definitions of lack thereof on
line 24 and 25 the definition of
principal instructural leader and
progress they you're looking for a
definition I I I think probably
instructional leader is elsewhere in
statute um you know this language was
was given to me um so I assume that that
was in statute and certainly rigorous
process um you know we we've used the
terms um in terms of adequate education
we just added rigor as a criteria for um
academic instruction so I I don't see a
necessity for a rigorous definition per
se okay I thank you I just don't
understand what rigorous process is of
trying to I'm reading this as a a people
a person who is interested in a position
trying to figure out where it's not
defined yeah I I through a process you
know I think anyone who um goes through
uh a process um to be assigned a role
such as that uh I think the school board
um would certainly from my experience go
through a rigorous process to make sure
that that person was qualified not
there's nothing Define it's just
whatever the school wants thank you
rep represent Damon did you have here
no represent mil thank you Mr chair and
thank you for bringing this forward uh
well the question that I would have
would it be possible under this language
uh for let's say in a small school
district for the uh School Board uh to
identify a local individual who's not
employed in the school district um has
no background really in education but
maybe back ground in business or
whatever uh could that person qualify
for uh this uh Personnel assigned
to um I I thank you for the question I
think that the um RSA says
administrative Personnel so it certainly
could be the business manager for
instance could be per assigned to
perform some of these functions uh
follow up yes go ahead uh so your intent
here is for somebody who's already
employed within the school district
might be either fulltime or parttime
yeah might be a principal for example
correct but it's not somebody from just
outside the school Community for example
to be hired be somebody within that's
your intent that's my intent and my
understanding of what's in statute now
thank you further questions representa
Aon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so in what way if any does the
post statute
address a school board member deciding
to or Schoolboard collectively deciding
to take on these
tasks um I I don't think that that would
fit under current
law um which says
administrative Personnel working in the
district and this is in 2A under 194 C5
thank you I don't think that School
Board member would qualify
there represent cascaden thank you uh Mr
chair thanks for taking my question um
if Personnel were assigned to perform
superintendent
Services let's just say um I don't know
a principal would they be held liable or
will the
superintendent who's going to be held
liable um I would think whoever is
assigned by uh the school board to
perform those Services okay whether
not right yeah yes okay thank
you further
Christina thank you chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee uh
Barett Christina from the school board
just Association uh we are not taking a
specific position on this bill um but I
do have um a couple uh matters for the
committee to consider and perhaps a
question or two for uh representative
cordelli to perhaps work on and bring an
amendment I'm looking at the language on
pay on lines 23 through
27 um I'm specifically the
superintendent of a single School
District may qualify for alternative
certification as a principal
instructional leader um there's no
current certification for principal
instructional leaders under the 506
rules that we've been talking about for
the last 45 minutes or so um I know that
that phrase principal instructional
leader was included in one of the drafts
of the 506 certification rules back in I
believe maybe mid
2022 um but the final version that came
out um of those rules um I think in uh
maybe April or May of 2023 does not con
Ain that phrase principal instructional
leader so when it says alternative
certification as a principal
instructional leader NH hsba thinks it
would be a better practice to relate the
alternative certification to something
to a position with which the Department
of Education is currently
certifying um also relative to um to the
uh uh uh the alternative certification
there is a
certification um called a district
administrator certification this is
Department of Education rule 50
[Music]
rator the district administrator
certification is I call a principal plus
their day-to-day responsibilities are
are primarily serving as a principal
within that K through 5 or K through six
School District um but yet they're
authorized under the certification rules
to sign off on perhaps Federal reports
and and and reports required by the
Department of Revenue administration
department of education so on and so
forth um so um uh uh the criteria um for
that District administrator
certification is three years experience
as a licensed principal 30 plus graduate
um 30 or more graduate or postback Oria
credits and they demonstrated ability to
provide the services under RSA 194 C4 um
and then there's some other application
procedures so um again without taking a
position on the bill I just wanted to
draw attention to um the alternative
certification as a principal
instructional leader again nsba thinks
to principal instructional leaders
should be amended to include something
that is already within the certification
positions at the Department of Education
so in representative Cordell if you
would want to work on that um please by
only reach out to Becky she knows the
certification rules um more than I but
we're certainly to help with that we're
certainly happy to help with that and
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions are there any questions of the
school boards
Association not seeing any you're up the
hook thank you oh wait a minute wait a
minute represent Panner yes yeah um Ju
Just how important do you think uh from
a school board's point of view is the
superintendent of the school well I mean
the super I mean you know uh Mr mlan and
Mr cascad and I Mark I forget if you
have a doctor Dr mlan perhaps um I mean
they they spoke about it you know nhba
does anywhere between four and I'd say
eight or 10 superintendent searches
every every year um and um you know the
the school board members or if they're
designating you know the search to a to
a committee you know you're looking for
the highest quality instructional leader
that you can possibly find to come in to
come into your your seu so I mean it it
it's the you know the chief you know the
chief operating Chief Operating Officer
Chief Executive Officer of your
corporation there the school board is
the board of directors then you've got
the guy running or woman running the
day-to-day
operations follow
yes so for school boards themselves
though how important is the
superintendent as the person that helps
the school board be the board of
directors I guess no um so so thank you
for the question representative um there
is a provision representative Cordell
you mentioned RSA 194 C4 paragraph 2 a
through r that references all sort of
the the operations with that are
responsible for the that the
superintendent is responsible for and
within there are I forget the sub exact
sub paragraph for the exact language but
there are the superintendent for one I
know in that in that statute is
responsible for providing um legal
guidance to the school board is
responsible for the daily administration
of of the school district is responsible
for advising the school district the
school board relative to policy
obligations and a couple other couple
other responsibilities in there where
the school board or the superintendent
is responsible for reporting to the
school board or assisting the school
board with some of the school board
obligations and responsibilities thank
you further questions just represent
Heath have a quick one um it's simply
with um in regard to liability um if if
a school district um was to hire
somebody uh a superintendent with
questionable uh a background or would
that if in fact the school district was
sued would that add to the the liability
of the overall School District in the
event of such a yeah manner thank you
for the question representative I mean
if the person that's being hired is
certified you know I mean they're at
least meting you know creating the they
at least met some some bare minimum
requirements you know I I I don't want
to comment on you know the
superintendent makes a mistake are they
you know was it an innocent mistake was
it incompetence was it something that
the district KN you know if you know if
if the superintendent was somehow con
you
know stealing money from his previous
job and you hire them and you're
stealing money again well maybe maybe
there's a level of you know issue with
you know your hiring process perhaps but
I mean you know I don't want to come up
with extreme extreme examples I mean is
the district going to get if the
district's going to get sued the
district's going to get sued and and
then you know we got to figure out was
their negligence that's the issue at
hand so not whether or not the person is
competent or not competent yeah one
other point too if I real could um I
mentioned the the the the district ad
administrator certification 400 students
no more than no more than 400 students
no more than school buildings just as as
the bill is written it's a
superintendent of a single School
District could qualify as alternative
certification to some degree this would
be a school board question who you want
to hire but just let's just be mindful
that the two largest school districts in
the state are single District saus that
being Manchester and nsha they're
probably going to want to have a
certified superintendent there but for
for the smaller districts K through four
districts with 50 kids 200 kids whatever
it might be um you know and just for the
the the the just background I apologize
for taking up time I know it's been a
long day um the district administrator
model um under the pertinent Department
of Education rule one school district
has used that model successfully for
probably 12 or 15 years now late 2000
early
2010s um and then there are two
districts um that have tried it and it
it it ended up not working for them so
they went back to the more traditional
model with a building level principal
and um a superintendent overseeing
overseeing the rest of the staff so it's
not used commonly but there are a couple
examples in New
Hampshire yep I was in one myself over
across the border in Maine y K through 8
I was the principal and we were paying
too much to Rumford for our SAU sad yeah
so we decided to go by ourselves k
through eight and then I took over as
combination principal superintendent yep
yep thank you yep so um any further
questions thank you very much thank you
y all righty uh that does complete that
bill we have no other cards on it so
we'll like to go into the next bill
1265 and 1265 is relative to the penalty
for failure to file School expenditure
reports and relative certain adequate
adequacy grants uh represent fellos is
the maker of that bill she's not here so
represent cordelli is going to uh
introduce it on her behalf uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you colleagues uh
Glenn cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolf bone oopy got it right this time in
the beautiful Lakes Region and uh I'd
like to introduce uh hb1
1265 which basically just uh addresses
uh the subject of failure to file school
reports and specifically public AC
publicy
and I believe there are several
instances um in um section one where uh
statutes and we do have a report here
from representative fellows that's going
around the table right
now any questions for represent cordelli
say it's not his Bill thank you very
much and then we would like to ask Mark
magello mag
magella
Pella I can't say it never have been
able to mark I apologize Mark
M welcome good good afternoon everyone
Mark Melo Department of Education um we
uh uh went to representative fellows
with a few housekeeping bills um you've
seen a lot a few of those bills um this
bill is also a housekeeping bill so if
you look at RSA 1984 D it requires the
doe2 and in requiring the doe2 they re
they list out who's required to submit
the doe2 it includes district and
Charters it does not include publicy so
that's the requirement to submit a doe2
then in RSA 1984 f um there is what are
the punishments for not doing a
doe2 and um extensions and who gets an
extension to be late on their doe2 and
in that area law um it includes Publicis
so there's an inconsistency who's
required to do it and who's could be
punished for not doing it so publicy
could be punished for doing something
they're not required to do so um so it's
just a it's a mix match and it's some
housekeeping um so if you strike public
Academy from the penalty we would just
have consistency on who is required to
do a doe2 and who could be punished for
it um I I put I put n um uh we don't
have a position for or against this we
did we did go to representative fellow
saying this is something we would like
to clean up I think previous sessions
you've seen bills to add public publicy
to who's required to do a
doe2 um so they'd be punished for not
doing a doe2 potentially and required to
do a
doe2 we sort of have no position either
way we would like the law to be
consistent
um so this bill as introduced would make
the law consistent um if
ifies um I know we've had some of these
conversations uh we get our we get our
do25 from districts districts have to do
that for two reasons to set taxes um
publicy can't raise taxes districts
raise taxes um and financial reporting
to the feds um and so the feds have
never asked for publicy if they ever did
ask for public academes we would come to
House Education look for a bill to
require that um but at this moment in
time um that section of the bill as
introduces um some housekeeping and
there's another section about adequacy
but I'll stop for questions about do 25s
and
publicy yes represent Miler uh thank
thank you for being here so are you
saying right now that publicy do not
have to file form 25 correct so those
Publicis would would include Co Brown
Pinkerton any others just those
two followup please yes
so who then are you saying that because
let's say let's take pinker as an
example pinkin gets students from dairy
primarily correct so who files the
report does dairy file report Derry
files the report so we get a doe 25 from
Derry um and and and that's and they
send their students to
[Music]
pickron
uh
so so how do we know what Pinkerton is
spending on
schools uh so we only have we don't know
what Pinkerton is doing specifically we
know what der's doing so we don't have
that
data excuse me Mr chair I don't maybe
I'm missing something
here
but Dair provides
tuition to Pinkerton correct Pinkerton
employees staff for that school to teach
the dairy children yes what is the
accountability then for how Pinkerton
spends their money from taxpayers from
dairy so at the state
level
uh I'm only talking about really
financial reporting from a financial
reporting perspective we don't have a
do25 from Pinkerton so we don't have any
insights into what Pinkerton is is
spending what Dairy can do at the local
level is they choose to go into use as
as a provider use Pinker as a provider
they can do whatever they do through the
the local process whether it is through
contracts whatever it may be um but the
state is not involved um in that process
that would be the accountability would
essentially be local at that at that
moment rep
luno thank you very much um what type of
and and thank you for taking my question
um Mr Manel what type of um
well how do I how do I ask a question I
guess um um under what sort of corporate
structure are
formed there and yeah I don't I don't I
don't know exactly I don't know um I
know der Pinkerton has been around for a
very long time um Co Brown I believe
also been around for a long time I I
don't know
exactly uh for example are they
for-profit or non nonprofit
businesses I can't answer I don't no
thank you I think if we look at our
records we did get the audit on
Pinkerton several years ago we had a
bill in that we did yeah and and we
looked at that audit and went through
it but that's as far as my
memor yes Pinkerton
and Pinkerton and C Brown from my years
at the department are considered public
private institutions now Pinkerton for
example has a a CTE Center so they have
in the past received State money for
that Center because they're a Regional
Vocational Center but Pinkerton also
takes students from Candia Auburn hamste
I don't know if it's Hamstead there are
a number of school districts that are
transitioned into Pinkerton and they
have a Board of Trustees as does cob
Brown yeah it's an independent much like
St Johnsbury
Academy another thing just to point out
as far as um if you go the route of
saying okay we want the law to be
consistent and we want publicy to be
required to submit to u2s and we want
them to be punished it would be as far
as punishing Pinkerton meaning
withholding State funding they're not
receiving adequacy so we can't punish
Dairy if Derry does their
do25 they're going to receive adequacy
but then Pinkerton doesn't do their doe
25 we're not paying adequacy to
Pinkerton so it would just be a
mechanical issue where we can't punish
for something Pinkerton didn't do or you
could write a laot to do that but that's
under this structure that wouldn't be
how just you know Crossing ad publicy in
the top line that wouldn't change that
accountability
structure but just something to it's the
it's the how law currently is being
implemented
so y further questions yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so do all the different
communities that tuition to Pinkerton do
individual Doe 25s
correct and there's no composite one for
correct that's because it's an
independent school it has a Board of
Trustees it doesn't not have elected
officials and it's it's bankroll with
there by those initial people that
contributed that
school
understand we went through the on that
we looked at all its assets its revenues
its expenditures and it came out
clean so it's it's functioning I think
that was when Erica was on AR Erica Leon
was the one that required that to come
in here and we did
that yes rep on M I do believe that
um I'm dating myself here but I do
believe that in the late
80s that the labor board did
indicate that Pinkerton and Cole Brown
were in fact public
schools for the purpose of organizing
unions I do believe that they did that
is a ruling that they did
have yeah I believe they have the
designation of being a public school um
but they're unique relative to most of
our
schools and Curr not retirement that's
right so if we're don't I'm going to
move on to the adequacy section I'll
just if there's any more questions on
okay yes so the adequacy section um oh
man uh back when hb2 and I don't even
know if it was the house or the Senate
but we changed the adequacy formula in
the budget and I think it might have
been the Senate phase but a lot of
things were being moved around in the
adequacy formula and there's two
calculations to do adequacy so there's
supposed to be we only use one but
there's supposed to be two calculations
there's one for all
municipalities Who Um send out tuition
you don't operate a school you're
supposed to do one calculation and for
all municipalities where they act any
municipality where they educate a
student within their District public
school um in any way um uh you're
supposed to do a separate calculation
and so the carv was supposed to be for
those districts that only send out
students and do not operate a school
you're supposed to do two calculations
do the regular adequacy calculation that
you've all been educated on and it was
was in hb2 and you're supposed to look
at what is their current expenditure
and then back out swept meaning what are
they paying tuition back out swept and
whatever the variance is is going to be
their adequacy Grant and so essentially
that would be a district school who has
a tuition bill that is less than the
adequacy Grant and so if we are made
informed that that is going on for
example if some District informed us if
we found out that a district was paying
tuition less than adequacy um we would
have to attempt to do that calculation
um currently I'm not doing that
calculation because I'm not aware of any
District that has a tuition bill that's
less than adequacy um so at the moment
it's not really being implemented um but
when we took that language out when we
took out that second calculation there
was an error in the law where basically
it says only calculate adequacy for
districts that educate students in house
so basically the law as as HB as passed
in hb2 it says only calcul adequacy for
communities that educate students and so
representative fellows noticed that
error and she informed us and she put it
into this bill so um that is another
housekeeping it it's not going to have
any fiscal impact because we are
currently paying adequacy as
constitutionally required um to
districts that educate students even if
it's all through tuition um so we're not
really following the plain meaning of
the law because it would result in um
essentially like defunding Albany which
we don't want to do um so that needs to
get fixed
bill any
questions anybody need the cliff
notes
okay thank you very much Mark thank
you and we have let's see no other cards
for that bill so we're going to close
down 1265 and that's the last bill for
okay